GOVERNANCE IN FINANCE WE ARE
GOING TO BE KICKING OFF THIS
MORNING'S HEARING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE -- ONCE WE HAVE A
FOURTH MEMBER RIDE TO COMMITTEE
IS A BUSY DAY WE HAVE ENERGY AND
EDUCATION IS WELL THAT WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AT MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
REQUEST FOR ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH WILL TAKE ACTION
ON ONCE WE ARE ABLE TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM.
CURRENTLY ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE ITEMS SIX SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE ITEM SEVEN SB
THREE EIGHTY IN ITEM.
EIGHT SB THREE EIGHTY ONE WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE -- ITEMS
THREE SB TWO EIGHTY SEVEN TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- IN EIGHT THE
TIME OF ACTION FOR THE COULD
SINK COUNTER WE'RE GONNA SEE
THERE'S ANY DISAGREEMENT FROM
THE COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO DO
SO AND I WANT.
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
CENTER NIELSEN FOR ALL OF HIS
WORK ON THAT BILL.
MEMBERS AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WITH
THAT COULD BE A MOVING TO OUR
FIRST BILL WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SENATOR HILL FOR ALL OF
HIS WORK ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ON THIS.
IMPORTANT ISSUE HE'S BRINGING
FORWARD YET AGAIN THIS YEAR THIS
IS SB TWO NINETY FOUR SENATOR
HILL.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBER -- TO PLEASURE TO BE
HERE WITH YOU THIS MORNING SB
TWO NINETY FOUR WILL AID
NONPROFIT AND RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BY EXPANDING THE PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION TO TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ASSESS
PROPERTY BUT ANNUALLY.
SPECIFICALLY IT WILL HELP TO
CHARITIES IN OUR STATE FROM DAY
ONE ONE OF WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT.
IF YOU ARE ALL AWARE FOR OF OUT
OF THE FIVE LEAST AFFORDABLE
RENTAL MARKETS NATIONWIDE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
NON PROFITS THAT DO NOT RECEIVE
ANY TAX CREDITS OR LOANS FROM
THE STATE OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES HAVE A
CAP.
PLACED ON THE AMOUNT OF PROPERTY
TAX THAT MAY BE EXEMPTED
ANNUALLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROVIDERS THAT DO RECEIVE TAX
CREDITS ARE LOANS FROM H. C. D.
HAVE NO LIMIT.
ON THE AMOUNT OF PROPERTY TAXES
THAT CAN BE EXEMPTED AND NO
MINIMUM PERCENTAGE REQUIRED OF
TENANTS WHO ARE LOW INCOME IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE A PRORATED.
PORTION OF THEIR PROPERTY TAXES
EXEMPTED ADDITIONALLY AT THE
REQUEST OF THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S OFFICE.
IN SB TWO NINETY FOUR WE LOWERED
THE THRESHOLD FOR A NONPROFIT TO
RECEIVE A PROPERTY TAX BENEFIT.
THE SAINT FRANCIS CENTER IN MY
DISTRICT RECENTLY WAS ABLE TO
ACQUIRE A FORTY EIGHT UNIT
APARTMENT COMPLEX.
ALL WITH PRIVATE DONATIONS AT A
COST OF TWENTY TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS.
THE BUILDING HAD EXISTING
TENANTS AND BECAUSE OF HOW TIGHT
THE EXPENSIVE IT IT AND EXPENSE
OF THE BAY AREA RENTAL MRKET IS
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO IMMEDIATELY
A VICTOR ALL OF THE TENNIS THAT
WERE NOT LOW INCOME.
AND THEY PAY THE PRICE THEY
RECEIVED A TAX BILL OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE COUNTY.
THE SENATE IF COUNTY ASSESSOR'S
OFFICE CALLED MY OFFICE AND
REQUESTED THAT THE SAINT FRANCIS
CENTER AND OTHER SIMILARLY
SITUATED CHARITIES GET A PRO
RATED PORTION OF THEIR PROPERTY
TAXES EXEMPTED.
AS LONG AS THEY HAVE AT LEAST
50% OF LOW INCOME TENANTS AND I
AGREED WITH THEM IT IS ONLY FAIR
AND IT AKES SENSE.
NOW I'M APPALLED THAT THE
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION TOOK A
LATE OPPOSED POSITION ON THIS
BILL.
FRANKLY THESE THE THESE FOLKS
ARE BOOKKEEPERS NOT POLICY
MAKERS THEIR JOB IS TO ASSESS
PROPERTY IN IN FAIRLY APPLY THE
LAWS THAT WE CREATE IF THEY WANT
TO BE BOOKED IF THEY WANT TO
MAKE POLICY DECISIONS.
IF THEY WANT TO TAKE.
THE POLICY POSITIONS THAN THEY
SHOULD GET THEMSELVES ELECTED TO
A POLICY MAKING BOARD OR BODY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
HAVE -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER HELLO --
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
CENTER HILL STANDS ON THAT ISSUE
SO -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND WILL OPEN IT UP FOR FOLKS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE BILL MISS
MARTIN FORCE OR SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR RAND
MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION MOST
PEOPLE KNOW H. UP AS THE LARGEST
PROVIDER OF CARE AND TREATMENT
OF PEOPLE WITH HIV IN THE WORLD.
WITH ABOUT ONE POINT THREE
MILLION PATIENTS WORLDWIDE WHAT
MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW IS IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS -- HF HAS
BECOME A MAJOR HOUSING PROVIDER
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WITH HOPES
TO EXTEND OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE -- RECOGNIZING THAT
HOUSING IS PART OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THE PEOPLE WITH
HIV AND OTHER MANAGEABLE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS FACE WAS IMPORTANT
FOR US TO GET PEOPLE INTO DECENT
HOUSING.
OUT OF THEIR CARS OFF OF
PEOPLE'S COUCHES AND DEFINITELY
OFF THE STREET WHERE THEY COULD
RECEIVE MEDICAL CARE -- AND LIVE
IN A DECENT ENVIRONMENT I'M IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE
OPENED UP SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE UNITS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BY GOING INTO -- HOTELS AND
MOTELS THAT HAVE HAVE BEEN RUN
DOWN SPENDING UP TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT TO RE
HAVE THEM TURN THEM INTO DECENT
HOUSING AND PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES.
ON WHAT WE HAVE IN THE SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE UNITS WE
HAVE FAR EXCEEDED THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR CAP AND PROPERTY
VALUATION THAT CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS -- WE ARE HERE DOING
THINGS THAT -- THAT HELP ALL THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA -- AND WE
THINK THAT THE PEOPLE OF THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD BE
HELPFUL TO US IN TERMS OF TAKING
SOME OF THE FINANCIAL BURDEN OFF.
BY -- INCREASING THE CAP TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS MARTIN
MA'AM THE MORNING IF YOU COULD
JUST GIVE US A FIRST CLASS
ORGANIZATION WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS RG
RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY.
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR HELL WE
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
HIS WORK ON THIS THIS YEAR --
AND IN PREVIOUS YEARS TO
ENCOURAGE NON PROFITS TO PROMOTE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I WE THINK
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
WHILE THE STATE IS IN A HOUSING
CRISIS.
AND ESPECIALLY IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY WHERE HOUSING PRICES ARE
EXTREMELY HIGH -- THIS BILL AIDS
NONPROFITS AND RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS IN PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES BY INCREASING PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION FROM TWENTY
MILLION TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION.
WE FEEL IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER TO PRESERVE AND ASSIST THE
EFFORTS OF NONPROFITS LIKE THE
SAINT FRANCIS CENTER IN REDWOOD
CITY WHICH PROVIDES NON PUBLICLY
FINANCED AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME RESIDENTS.
LOWERING THE REQUIRED PERCENTAGE
OF LOW INCOME TENANTS AND PRO
RATING THE EXEMPTION BASED ON
LOW INCOME TENNESSEE WHAT --
ALLEVIATE DISPLACEMENT THAT CAN
RESULT WHEN A CHARITY PURCHASES
THE BUILDING WITH EXISTING
TENANTS AS WAS RECENTLY THE CASE
WITH THE ST FRANCIS CENTER.
TO CENTER THAT CENTER HELP
MENTION.
AND WOULD ALLOW THEM TO USE
THESE FUNDS TO HELP MORE
FAMILIES SECURE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
ORDER SUPPORT OF SB JENNY.
FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING CENTER
HERE WOULD YOU MIND IF WE STEPS
RECORDER COMMITTEE.
A MORE THAN HAPPY TO LIVE I
THINK I THINK YOU SO MUCH SIR
AND I DO APOLOGIZE IN THE CENTER
SIR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WIRE.
WIRE PRESENT MORLOCK BELL.
THE PRESENT HERTZBERG RICARDO
[inaudible]
RESIDENT NIELSEN.
NIELSEN PRESENT WIENER YOU HAVE
A QUORUM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'D CENTER
HELP BEFORE WE GO TO YOUR OTHER
FOLKS IN SUPPORT WITH ACTIVITY
JUST TAKE A QUICK VOTE ON
CONSENT IF THAT WORKS FOR YOU.
MEMBERS AS WE JUST DISCUSSED WE
HAVE THREE ITEMS CONSENT WITH I
LIKE TO ADD A FOURTH WE HAVE
ITEM SIX SB THREE SEVENTY NINE
NINE SEVEN SB THREE EIGHTY ITEM
EIGHT SB.
THREE EIGHTY ONE IN WITH THE
INDULGENCE OF THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
ITEM THREE SB TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
TO THE CONSENT IS ANY OBJECTION
ADDING A FOURTH ITEM TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
HEARING TO SEE NO OBJECTION IS
MANCHESTER CAN YOU PLEASE CALL --
DO EMOTION I APOLOGIZE WITH THE
MOTION.
ALL RIGHT CENTER TADO -- MOVES
TO CUTTING COUNTER I APOLOGIZE
MISSING CHESTER FOR CAN PLEASE
CALL ROLL CALL AND CONTENT.
YES MCGUIRE I'M MORE LOCK BELL
BELL I HERTZBERG HER TITLE.
HELLO I NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
RESUME CURRENTLY HE ENJOYS THE
THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA OPEN
HELLO I SINCERELY APOLOGIZE.
I CAN NOW OPENING UP TO THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF CENTER
HILLS BILL IF YOU'RE TALKING
PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME
TO THE MICROPHONE WE'RE ASKING
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORTED
YOU TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING SIR CAN YOU PLEASE
CONFIRM MIKE FRONTAGE AND GIVE
US YOUR FIRST LASSEN
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US TODAY.
I GOOD MORNING JIMMY FROM IN
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN SUPPORT GOOD TO SEE SIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT NOW WOULD LIKE RICHARD
OVER THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE IN THIS
TIME.
AND WE INVITE.
THE GENTLEMAN WHO MAYBE POST
PLEASE JOIN US HERE AT THE FRONT
THAT'S OKAY SIR.
WE WELCOME YOU.
JUST GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST
ORGANIZATION AND THEN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS SIR AND THANKS FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MCGUIRE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF JESSE
SALINAS YELLOW COUNTY ASSESSOR
AND CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
AND I HAD FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE
TO APOLOGIZE THAT WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO SUBMIT.
THE DOCUMENTS IN TIME OUR
OPPOSITION LETTER AND IT
ACTUALLY I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
APOLOGIZE FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE
THAT HE WAS INFORMED OF IT THE
WAY WOOD OF A LIGHT AS YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALL LEARNING FROM THE NEW
PORTAL THAT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS HE
DIDN'T RECEIVE THAT IN A TIMELY
MATTER AS WELL SO WE APOLOGIZE
SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR THAT -- BUT
WANTED AT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY WE WE DON'T SEE
THIS FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT WE
ARE.
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT THIS FROM
AN ADMINISTRATIVE STANDPOINT WE
HAVE CONCERNS THAT IN THE PAST
THERE HAVE BEEN ABUSES RELATED
TO THIS BACK IN THE EIGHTIES AND
EVEN INTO THE NINETIES AND WE'RE
JUST CONCERNED FROM AN
ADMINISTRATIVE STANDPOINT THAT.
WE CAN REINVENT THOSE ERRORS
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD LEGISLATION TO
HELP PUT THOSE PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE AND WE DO APPRECIATE
SENATOR REQUIRES EFFORT T TRY
AND IDENTIFY EFFORTS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE UNDERSTAND
THAT'S IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT AGAIN
WE WE HAD SERIOUS CONCERNS FROM.
OUR IMPLEMENTATION STANDPOINT AS
ADMINISTRATORS OF THIS THANK YOU.
IT'S JUST THINGS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME OVER
HAVE YOU HOLD THERE IF WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
THAT'S OKAY SIR WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE AN OPEN IT UP TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED OR HAVE
ANY SWISHING IS ON THIS BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THE
MICROPHONE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE OPPOSED.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
GOOD MORNING DAVID GUISBOROUGH
DEPUTY ASSESSOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND THEN WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION WITH FOR THE SYSTEM
REASONS TO THE MINISTRY OF
CHALLENGES.
WE ARE CONCERNED THIS WILL BE AN
IMITATION FOR SCANDALS NOT NOT
WITH TO DIRECT TO THE NINES OR
THE AIDS FOUNDATION BUT THE
OTHER.
BUT THEIR COMMUNITIES OUT THERE
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES WE HAD
SCANDALS WERE CAN VERY CONCERNED
WITH A REPEAT OF THE SAME TYPE
ISSUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER DEPUTY ASSESSOR GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY.
WE LIKE TO BE A TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED AT THIS TIME YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THE MICROPHONE.
BRING TO A LAST CALL FOR
OPPOSITION.
NOW CAN WE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE RECEIVING ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
SENATOR HILL.
SURE -- IS CENTER HILL ON BEHALF
OF CENTER BÃO IF YOU WANT TO
BE A TO RESPOND.
THANK YOU VERYMUCH MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL FOR THE
CALL FOR THE QUESTION OR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND.
THE ASSESSOR'S CLAIM IS THAT YOU
KNOW IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
THERE WERE ABUSES AND THAT'S WHY.
THIS WAS ESTABLISHED AS A AND
AND WE MADE CHANGES TO IT PRIOR
TO THAT THERE WAS A 20%
REQUIREMENT FOR A LOW INCOME WE
ARE NOW BRINGING THAT 250%.
AND SO WE ARE ACTUALLY NOT GOING
AS FAR AS HISTORICALLY IT HAD
BEEN -- THE IDEA OF FRAUD AT THE
REQUEST OF THE ASSESSORS IN THE
PREVIOUS -- ITERATION OF THIS
LEGISLATION INCREASING THE CAP --
THEY REQUIRED UP FORM FILLED OUT
TO BE FILLED OUT A WELFARE
EXEMPTION SUPPLEMENTAL AFFIDAVIT
OF HOUSING THAT -- NOW IS
REQUIRED OF ALL OF THOSE NON
PROFITS TO FILL OUT AT THEIR
REQUEST IN A IN THE UNDER THE
PENALTY OF PERJURY THEY SIGN TO
IDENTIFY EXACTLY.
THE AMOUNT OF LOW INCOME TENANTS
THERE ARE HOW MUCH THEY WERE --
NUMBER PROPORTIONS IN THE
HOUSEHOLD THE ANNUAL HOUSEHOLD
INCOME MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE RENT
THAT CAN BE CHARGED ACTUAL RENT
CHARGE THROUGH THERE IS AT THAT
THE ASSESSORS REQUEST THEY HAVE
THE INFORMATION THAT IS
NECESSARY FOR THE EXEMPTION.
THEY ALSO HAVE A LOT OF THE
TOWARD IF THEY FEEL THAT THERE'S
A VIOLATION SOMEWHERE THEY CAN
GO IN AND AUDIT THOSE -- NON
PROFITS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE ACTING RESPONSIBLY AND IT
AND ACCORDING TO LAW SO WE HAVE
DONE EVERYTHING THAT THEY
REQUESTED HISTORICALLY IN THE
PAST THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE INCREASED HOUSING.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
NONPROFITS THAT USED THEIR FUNDS
RAISED THROUGH THEIR FUND
RAISING CAN PROVIDE THAT HOUSING
WITHOUT A TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR TAX BILL
FROM THEIR COUNTY ASSESSOR.
OR TAX COLLECTORS.
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS AND FEEL THAT IT'S THE
APPROPRIATE SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIBEL MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH WILL YOU SAID AT THE
CLOSING STATEMENTS OR BALLOTS OR
ANY FOLLOW UP ON THAT SIR.
THANK YOU CENTER TITLE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU CENTER HERE WAS THAT
YOUR CLOSING STATEMENT RESPECT
GAS NOVEL MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SO -- MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SEE IF THERE IS A MOTION TO
BE ABLE TO PROVE SB TWO NINETY
FOUR THIS IS A DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
HURTADO AGAIN TO PASS YOUR
PREPARATIONS ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE MISSING JUST REQUIRE HI.
I'M OR LOCK BILL.
I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
HELLO HI NIELSEN WIENER.
I CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTES INTO HELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH WITNESSES THANK YOU MRS
THINGS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WITH A GREATER
THANK YOU GO EXTINCT.
MEMBERS IF YOU GET EXCUSE ME I
LAYS CHEN AS YOU PLEASE GIVE US
THIRTY SECONDS WE'RE GOING TO DO
A QUICK ORGANIZATION -- AND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU JIM WOOD I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO INTERVIEW CENTER
STONE CENTER STONE IS GREEN VAN
SEEN SB.
THREE SIXTY FOUR THIS IS FOCUS
ON PROPERTY TAX.
PROBABLY TAXES IS ON A FOUR IS
SENIORS AND DISABLED VETERANS WE
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT SAY THANK
YOU TO CENTER STONE FOR ALL OF
HIS WORK -- ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL.
THEY'RE STILL THE FLOORS OR SIR.
THANK YOU HONORABLE CHAIR
MCGUIRE SANDERS -- BELLINGER
COTTO IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT SB.
THREE SIXTY FOUR A PROBLEM THAT
IS CURRENTLY PLAGUING
CALIFORNIA'S OR AMOUNT OF
VETERANS WHO ARE HOMELESS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA HAD TEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
HOMELESS VETERANS ACCORDING TO
ALMOST 30%.
OF THE NATION'S TOTAL HOMELESS
VETERANS POPULATION.
VETERANS OF SACRIFICE FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND IN RETURN LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING IN THEIR
POWER TO HELP THEM SUCCEED.
THERE'S NO SINGLE SOLUTION THAT
IS GOING TO SOLVE THIS CRISIS
OVERNIGHT REASONS FOR THE LARGE
NUMBERS OF HOMELESS VETERANS ARE
NUMEROUS AND VERY COMPLEX. TO
THE BIGGEST FACTORS THOUGH ARE
THE EXTREME SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND LIVABLE
INCOME.
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR COMES TO
ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS OF
VETERANS FACED BY DOING THE
FOLLOWING FIRST SB THREE SIXTY
FOUR CAPS THE PROPERTY TAXES ON
THE PRIMARY RESIDENCE OF AN
HONORABLY DISCHARGED VETERAN.
OVER HE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE AS
YOU KNOW THESE THE THE TREASURER --
TAX COLLECTOR IN EACH COUNTY CAN
RAISE THAT PROPERTY TAX UP 2% OF
BASE BASED ON THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX SECOND IT
EXEMPTS PROPERTY TAXES ON ALL
1100% DISABLED VETERANS LIVING
IN THEIR PRIMARY RESIDENCE --
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT MY
DISTRICT AS YOU KNOW -- MY
DISTRICT VERY CLOSE TO CAMP
PENDLETON AND MANY NONPROFITS
THAT EXIST OUT THERE TO PROVIDE
FREE HOMES THERE SPECIALLY BUILT
FOR THESE VETERANS TO DO THOUGH
THE WHITE HALL WAYS THE WHOLE
CASE. TO GET THEM INTO BETTER TO
GET HIM INTO A SHOWER IF THEY'RE
DOUBLE OR TRIPLE AMPUTEES BUT
THE ONE THING THE LIVES OF THOSE
HOMES THAT THEY GET.
THE BENEFICIARY OF IS A PROPERTY
TAXES AND MANY OF THEM CAN'T
WORK ON THE SITE TENS OF THE GET
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AREN'T SUFFICIENT TO ALLOW THEM
TO STAY.
IN THEIR HOMES. TWELVE OTHER
STATES ALREADY HONOR THEIR
VETERANS WITH FULL PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTIONS LET'S MAKE CALIFORNIA
BE THE NEXT TO DO SO SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR PROVIDES A BASIC STEP
IN HELPING OUR VETERAN COMMUNITY.
BY EXPANDING THE CURRENT
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION AND
CURRENT -- REACH OF THE LAW
CALIFORNIA IS HONORING THE
SACRIFICES OF OUR VETERANS AND
PROVIDED THEM A WAY TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES THIS BILL IS A REAP
INVEST BEFORE -- FOR WHICH
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
SOME VERY GRATEFUL WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE THIS TIME.
WE WELCOME IF YOU PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR FIRST AND LAST YEAR
ORGANIZATION WELCOME SIR GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS HOWEVER WE
DID NOT HAVE A LETTER SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL THAT MY CLIENTS
HAVE.
SUPPORTED THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION IN THE PAST AND WE
WILL WORK WITH AUTHOR TO GET A
SUPPORT LETTER.
THANK YOU BRING YOUR THREE LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO MAY BEING
SUPPORTED PLEASE ADVANCE AT THIS
TIME.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BE A WELCOME
ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF YOU
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ASK OFFER THOSE WERE OPPOSED.
IT'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
TO BE RECEIVED FROM ME WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
ALSO WELCOME THE MOTION AS WELL.
WE HAVE A MOTION MY CENTER TODD --
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
THANKS TONY JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT --
INVENTIONS ACROSS THE STATE AT
WILL BENEFIT FROM YOUR ACTION
WERE VERY GRATEFUL I WOULD YOU
LIKE TO HAVE A CLOSING STATEMENT
SIR I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT ON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH IN A
SENSE REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE
THIS IS A DO PASSED.
TO VETERANS AFFAIRS WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
TITLE THE SAME JUST A ROLL CALL
VOTE PLEASE.
HI WHY I'M MORE LONG BILL.
BILL I HERTZBERG.
FURTADO FOR TITLE I NIELSEN
WIENER.
I CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
CENTER STONE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN -- IN AS FOLKS
COMING WILL ADD ON AS WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
THE CALL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A WE WANNA
WELCOME -- FORMER SENATOR AND
RETIRED JUDGE QUENTIN KOPP TO
THE MEETING TODAY WELCOME AND
THE CENTER IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN -- SO HERE'S THE DEAL WE
HAVE NOAUTHORS -- NAY AND DATA
VERY EXCITING SO.
WE'RE GONNA SEE IF CENTER RUBIO
IS IN THE HOUSE WELCOME CENTER
RUBIO YOU ARE RIGHT ON TIME.
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
ABOUT TO ASK -- RETIRED SENATOR
COP TO BE A TO DO OUR
INTERMISSION DANCE -- SO I YOU
SAY NO IT'S IT'S YOU YOU'RE
YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE GOOD.
HEY NOTE FOR THE ACCOMMODATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LAYS IN GERMAN WE ARE GOING --
TO WELCOMED CENTER RUBIO HERE ON
SENATE BILL FOUR THIRTEEN
FOCUSING IN ON AND SANG GRAVY
OLD WATER QUALITY AUTHORITY WE
APPRECIATE ALL HER OF HER WORK
ON THIS BILL.
THEN RUBIO THE FLOOR IS YOURS IF
I TO STEP OUT IS NOT BEING RUDE
TO YOU I TO GO VOTE EDUCATION AS
WELL AS ENERGY AND I APOLOGIZE.
ABOUT ALL TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
SENATOR BALLOT FIVE TO STEP OUT
SOON RUBIO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MA'AM.
I WILL NOT TAKE IT PERSONALLY I
PROMISE.
THANK YOUGOOD MORNING MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HAD TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ON SB. FOUR ONE THREE
A DISTRICTS PACIFIC BELL THAT
WOULD MODIFY THE ELECTION
SCHEDULE FOR THE SAN GBRIEL
BASIN WATER QUALITY AUTHORITY.
THE AUTHORITY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
DEVELOPING FINANCING AND
IMPLEMENTING.
GROUNDWATER TREATMENT PROGRAMS
IN THE SAN GABRIEL BASIN.
IT IS GOVERNED BY SEVEN MEMBERS.
TO INCLUDING LOCAL CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS AND PREVIOUSLY CITY
COUNCIL ELECTIONS WERE HELD AN
ODD EVEN I'M SORRY ON ODD
NUMBERED YEARS AND THE AUTHORITY
BOARD ELECTION WAS HELD ON EVEN
NUMBERED YEARS.
HOWEVER RECENT CHANGES HAVE COST
CITIES AND MY DISTRICT TO CHANGE
TO EVEN NUMBER YEARS IT GETS A
LITTLE CONFUSING HOWEVER.
NOW WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY IN THE
CITY ELECTIONS HAPPENING AT THE
SAME TIME WHICH IS CAUSING SOME
CONFUSION.
AND UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
AUTHORITY MUST HOLD A SPECIAL
ELECTION TO FILL BOARD VACANCIES.
AND CONSIDERABLE TIME AND COST
AS EXTENDED.
SB FOUR ONE THREE SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BY STARRING THE
AUTHORITY'S BOARD ELECTION AND
CITY COUNCIL ELECTIONS.
AND ADDING. TO THE UPDATING.
IN UPDATING PROCEDURES FOR
FILLING A VACANCY TO ELIMINATE
SPECIAL ACTIONS IN CASES RECEDE
AS ONLY THEY CAN FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
THE BOARD DISCUSSED THESE
CHANGES TO THE PUBLIC.
WITH -- WITH WORKSHOPS IN
HEARINGS AND UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED
A POSITION SUPPORTING THEM AFTER
HEARING OPPOSITION FROM THE
PUBLIC SO ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL
JUST REMINDS THE ELECTION
PROCESS. TO ENSURE WE DON'T
SPEND MONEY ON SPECIAL ACTIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR AND I'M SORRY LET
ME INTRODUCE MY GUESTS HERE WHO
WILL BE ALSO TESTIFYING RANDY.
SHOULDER MAN AND HE'S THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
SENIOR ENGINEERING FOR THE SAN
GABRIEL BASIN WATER QUALITY
AUTHORITY AT THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU CENTER.
GOOD MORNING.
FOR THANK YOU -- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- IN ADDITION TO WHAT
THE SENATOR RUBIO AS INDICATED
TO THIS BILL WOULD ALSO --
CONSOLIDATE SOME REPORTING THAT
ARE -- AGENCIES REQUIRED TO DO
UNDER ENABLING ACT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO PUT A GROUNDWATER
REMEDIATION PLAN TOGETHER SINCE
WE OVERSEE THE GROUNDWATER BASIN
WHICH IS HAS ALSO OF OP.
OPERABLE UNITS THAT NEED TO BE
CLEANED UP -- WE REPORT ON A
SEMI ANNUAL BASIS ON THE STATUS
OF THAT CLEAN UP. TO THE STATE
BOARD AND THE LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD -- THIS BILL WOULD ALSO A
CONSOLIDATE THAT INTO ONE REPORT
ANNUALLY WHICH WE ALREADY DO --
SO IN ADDITION -- TO HELPING OUR
ELECTIONS WITH THE CITY'S MAKING
THAT.
MORE OF A EASY PROCESS FOR THE
ALL THE CITY CENTRE VAULTS SINCE
WE HAVE TO GO TO OUTSIDE EACH
CITY DURING EACH ELECTION STYLE
CYCLE GET THE NOMINATIONS AND GO
BACK TO THEM HOW DO RESOLUTIONS
FOR THE THE VOTES AFTER THE FACT --
THIS BILL WOULD REALLY SIMPLIFY
THE PROCESS OF YOURS OR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE USER ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN STEVE
BAKER WITH HER AND REDUCES HIS
FOR THE UPPER SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER AGENCY WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR.
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
TO CLEAR UP THESE ISSUES AND
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
A OTHERS SPEAKERS GET ROMAN OURS
ON BEHALF OF SINGULAR VALLEY
WATER COMPANY IN SUPPORT -- TO
HAVE SPEAKERS -- OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE PLEASE COME.
FOR THERE'S A OPPOSITION
[inaudible] NINE QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THE BOARD
FOR THE TIME TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
I ASKED RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO DO
PASSED TO THE ENVIRONMENT
QUALITY COMMITTEES EMOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION -- CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
REQUIRE MORE LOT BELL I KNOW I
HERTZBERG.
RICARDO.
RICARDO I'D NIELSEN WIENER
[inaudible] TO ALL. TO VOTE IN
FAVOR WILL HELP KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND WE HAVE -- SIR CABALLERO SIR
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE'RE DONE.
OKAY THE ROLE OPEN -- SENATOR --
MCGUIRE WILL BE BACK IS AN
EDUCATION COMMITTEE VOTING AND
HE'LL BE BACK SHORTLY SO -- THIS
IS SB -- FOUR ONE FOUR OF SMALL
SYSTEM WATER QUALITY AUTHORITY.
AND SIR YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR BELL AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
pSMALL SYSTEM WATER THIRTY ACTIVE.
TWENTY NINETEEN THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
HAS IDENTIFIED NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEM
STATEWIDE THAT CHRONICALLY
FAILED TO SERVE SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
THE THE SYSTEMS LACK THE
FINANCIAL MANAGERIAL AND
TECHNICAL RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS ONGOING CONTAMINATION
AND INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES.
NECESSARY TO OPERATE A HIGH
FUNCTIONING WATER SYSTEM.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
SYSTEMS ARE SMALL RURAL SYSTEMS
SERVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. TOO MANY OF WHICH
ARE IN MY DISTRICT.
LET THERE BE NO DOUBT THIS IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND A
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION IS LONG
OVERDUE. ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TURN ON THE TAP AND
CANNOT DRINK THE WATER.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED MANY
LAWS AND ADDRESSED.
ADDRESS SOME ELEMENTS OF THE
WATER ACCESSIBILITY ISSUE
INCLUDING CAPITAL FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CONSOLIDATION
WHEN AN ANCHOR TENANT.
AGENCY IS NEARBY.
HOWEVER LASTING CHANGES CHANGES
TO THE UNDERLYING GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE OF FAILING COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS IS NEEDED TO
CREATE ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS. TO
ADDRESSING PROBLEMS WERE NEARLY
NEARBY ANCHOR AGENCIES ARE NOT
SUITABLE AND WE'RE ECONOMIC
SCALE IS REQUIRED TO HAVE
SUSTAINABLE SYSTEMS.
SB FOUR ONE FOUR PROPOSES TO
MERGE THE SMALL NON COMPLIANT
WATER SYSTEMS INTO A LARGER MORE
ROBUST PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM THEY
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IMPROVED
ECONOMIES OF SCALE.
ACCESS TO STATE BACKED CAPITAL
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE STREAMLINED
MANAGERIAL FUNCTIONS AND
ENHANCED FINANCIAL CAPACITY.
SB FOUR ONE FOUR WOULD
COMPLEMENT EXISTING STATE WATER
BOARD CONSOLIDATION POWER
INCLUDING THOSE PREVIOUSLY
IMPLEMENTED.
IT IS A NEW TOOL IN THE TO A
TOOL BOX.
LAST YEAR MY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIFTY PASSED THIS
COMMITTEE AND SINCE THEN WE HAVE
WORKED WITH STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
AND LAUGH GO TO MAKE THE BILL
EVEN STRONGER.
SENATE BILL FOUR ONE FOUR IS A
CRUCIAL STEP TOWARDS PROVIDING A
BASIC HUMAN RIGHT.
CLEAN AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
DRINKING WATER TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OUR DANIEL
COATS AND THE EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT -- AND DANIELLE
BLANCHET FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MINUTES MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU AND ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND UNDERSTAND THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME OF US BUT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY COMMITTEE
CORRECT YES THAT IS CORRECT THE
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF SB FOUR FOURTEEN TODAY I'M
DANIEL COATS WITH EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
A WATER WASTEWATER AND RECYCLED
WATER PROVIDER THAT SERVES EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN WESTERN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
AS AN ORGANIZATION EASTERN HAS
DIRECT EXPERIENCE WITH
CONSOLIDATING RIPARIAN SYSTEMS.
WITH FAILING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SEVERE CONTAMINATION AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WHILE THE STATE BOARD HAS THE
POWER TO CONSOLIDATE SYSTEMS
THEIR STORY IS CONSTRAINED WHEN
THERE IS NO VIABLE RECEIVING
AGENCY SB FOR FOURTEEN ADDRESSES
THIS BY ALLOWING CHRONICALLY
UNDER PERFORMING SYSTEMS RE
EMERGED.
THROUGH A STEP BY STEP PROCESS
THAT IDENTIFIES DEFINES TIMELINE
INTO A MORE ROBUST AND
FUNCTIONAL SYSTEM.
THE PROCESS UTILIZES QUALIFIED
APPOINTED ADMINISTRATORS TO FORM
THE MARK MORE COMPETENT
SUCCESSOR AGENCIES.
AND AND IT'S IMPLEMENTED THROUGH
THE LOCAL LASKO PROCESS.
SB FOURTEEN FOR FOURTEEN
PROVIDES A TOOL TO THE STATE
BOARD THAT WE BELIEVE ADDRESSES.
BOTH THE NEAR TERM NEED FOR
INTERVENTION AND THE LONG TERM
OBJECTIVE OF CONFERENCE REFORM.
WE APPRECIATE THE GUIDANCE OF
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AN ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE WATER BOARD AND
THOSE OTHERS THAT WERE MENTIONED
BY THE SENATOR.
WHO WORKED WITH US TO IMPROVE
THE TRANSPARENCY AND FLEXIBILITY
THE BILL?
AND ALLOWING IT TO SERVE AS A
TOOL IN ADDRESSING THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA.
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE BELIEVE SB
FOUR FOURTEEN WILL ULTIMATELY
HELP INSURE THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE.
HAVE SAFE AND RELIABLE DRINKING
WATER ON A DAILY BASIS AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE A FOUR FOUR
FOURTEEN THANK YOU -- OTHERS
SPEAKERS YEAH DANIEL BLASTED
HIDING WITH CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION THANKYOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY WE ARE PROUD TO BE CO
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS OF SB.
FOUR FOURTEEN AS WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL WILL -- HELP -- AT BRING
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER TO A
LARGE PORTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
THE CURRENTLY DOES NOT HAVE IT --
AS NOTED BY THE AUTHOR IN A CO
SPONSOR AS BEFORE FOURTEEN SEEKS
O BRIDGET AND AN IMPORTANT GAP
IN THE STATE'S CONSOLIDATION
AUTHORITY.
I'M SETTING UP A UNIQUE PROCESS
FOR CONSOLIDATION THAT WHILE
COMPLIMENTARY DOES NOT MERE
EXISTING AUTHORITIES.
THERE ARE SEVERAL IMPORTANT
REASONS FOR THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
A LOCALLY CONTROLLED PUBLIC
PROCESS IS ESSENTIAL TO LONG
LASTING GOOD GOVERNANCE.
CUSTOMERS CAN IN FULL AND SHOULD
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN DECISIONS
RELATED TO THE DELIVERY OF SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
SB FOUR FOURTEEN ENTRANCE
FUNDAMENTAL STEPS THAT ENSURE
COMMUNITIES WILL HAVE A VOICE IN
THE FUTURE OF THEIR WATER SUPPLY.
FROM ENGAGEMENT WITH COUNTY
LAUGH GO TO REPRESENTATION ON A
LOCALLY ELECTED BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
SECOND IT INCLUDES FIRM
DEADLINES THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
HAVING A DEFINITIVE TIMELINE IS
ESSENTIAL WHEN THE STATE BOARD
IMPOSES DEADLINES TO THEIR
EXISTING MANDATORY CONSOLIDATION
PROCESS.
THEY WORK AND WE RECOGNIZE IT
WILL REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL
HOWEVER WE FEEL IT'S A PRUDENT
INVESTMENT TO EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS SYSTEMS THAT CANNOT BE
CONSOLIDATED THROUGH OTHER MEANS --
EVEN WITH THE EXISTING AUTHORITY
THAT THE STATE BOARD HAS TO
CONSOLIDATE THERE STILL ARE OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SYSTEMS THAT
DO NOT HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER.
WE TRULY BELIEVE THAT SB.
FOUR FOURTEEN PROVIDES ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX IT IS NOT
MEANT TO SUPERSEDE OTHER
AUTHORITIES.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE WORK BY
THE COMMITTEE STAFF -- TO
RECOMMEND AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
EVER MAKE THAT EXPLICIT THAT IT
IS JUST ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX BUT A VERY IMPORTANT --
ONE THE TIME IS NOW TO ADDRESS
THESE CHALLENGES FACING OUR
STATE SB FOR FOURTEEN PROVIDE
THIS IS DATEABLE PATH FORWARD TO
HELP ACHIEVE THAT GOAL AND WE
WERE ACTUALLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THE MORNING KRISTY FOIL ON
BEHALF OF THE THREE VALLEY'S
MISCIBLE WATER DISTRICT HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THE BIG WITH THEIR ANDROID
ASSOCIATES FOR THE UPPER SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
AGENCY IN SUPPORT.
KATHY VIA TELEWORK METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
JACK WELCOME BEHALF OF LONG
BEACH WATER DEPARTMENT ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
IN MORNING PAMELA MILLER WITH
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF LEFT
COAST AND WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL.
I WANT TO JUST SAY VERY BRIEFLY
ON A THINK THE AUTHOR HER STAFF
AND OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
FOR WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH CAL
AAFCO -- WHERE AN INTERNAL PART
OF THE PROCESS AND OF THE FAN
WONDERFUL PARTNERS SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT?
OF WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED AND
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU ON JUST ONE MINOR THING
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THANK
YOU.
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE HAVE A POSITION OF
SUPPORT AND AMEND ON THE BILL
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS.
FOR CONTINUING TO WORK WITH US
ON THIS ONE ISSUE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING BASS A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA ANA
WATERSHED PROJECT AUTHORITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR IS THE RESULT
BEHALF THE MISSILE WATER
DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY THE
LOS ORIGINALS WATER DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
NOMADIC WITH THE CITY OF
RESPONSE PART.
JASON I COULD WITH THAT'LL STING
GILBERT ROBESON BETH SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE SAME CISCO PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ALSO IN
SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO OUR MEETING.
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING I AM I
I DIDN'T DON'T HAVE TO REPEAT
FOR ALL OF YOU BUT I WELL HOW
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AND
COMMITMENT.
TO CREATING A STRONGER ROLE
CALIFORNIA GENERALLY -- WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THE ISSUE OF
ADDRESSING SAFE AND UNSAFE
DRINKING WATER IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY COACHELLA VALLEY.
FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND I AGREE
WITH THE SENATOR AND WITH THE
SPONSORS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADDRESSING GOVERNANCE IN MAKING
SURE KIND OF GOVERNANCE
SOLUTIONS MATCH UP WITH ARE.
A NEED FOR FOR ON GOING FUNDING
TO SUPPORT SAFE DRINKING WATER.
WE ALL HAVE -- CAM ELEVATED A
COUPLE ISSUES OF CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT NOTHING IN THIS BILL
DELAYS OR CREATES INCREASED
UNCERTAINTY FOR COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR SO MANY YEARS --
AND THERE'S WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO
SEE SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH.
THE SENATOR WITH THE COMMITTEE
IN WITH WITH CO SPONSORS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE CREATING
THROUGH THIS BILL CREATE AN
EXTRA TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
AND DOESN'T -- DOESN'T GET AWAY
DOESN'T FURTHER DELAY SO MANY
EFFORTS THAT ARE UNDER WAY AND
HAVE BEEN UNDER WAY. TO SECURE
SAFE DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN
GOING TO REITERATE FOR
APPRECIATION FOR THE CO SPONSORS
FOR CONTINUING TO BRING THIS
ISSUE AROUND GOVERNANCE FORWARD.
THE CENTER OF COURSE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU THROUGHOUT THE SESSION TO
MAKE THIS A SUCCESSFUL EFFORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HIM AGAIN
I SAID EARLIER AND I APOLOGIZE
IT WAS ON HERE AS I WAS VOTE
INTO AT THE COMMITTEES THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
MORNING AND YOU CAN GIVES ORDERS
LAST MICRODON YOU'RE GOOD.
THIS IS MY MY NAME'S JENNIFER
CLARY IN THE WATER POLICY
PROGRAM MANAGER AT CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
SPONSORS IN IMPROVING THIS BILL.
YEAH AS PHOEBE'S NOTED NOTED OUR
CONCERNS IT'S MY STATE A COUPLE
SPECIFIC AREAS ONE IS WE'RE
CONCERNED IT'S AMERICA THIS BILL
JUST MAKE IT A LOT MORE
EXPENSIVE. TO RUN OUR WATER
SYSTEMS OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR OUR ECONOMIES OF SCALE.
THINGS LIKE TRANSFERRING
LIABILITIES IS A CAN BE A LARGE
ISSUE THE OTHER THING.
HERE WE GO FOR IT IN THIS IS
GOING TO GO FROM VOLUNTEER
BOARDS TO PAYING BOARD MEMBERS
TWO AND A FIFTY DOLLARS PER DIEM
WHICH YOU AT WHICH IS ACTUALLY
MORE THAN CURRENT STATUTES SO.
THAT'S A BIG CHANGE AND BELIEVE
ME WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
LITTLE WATER SYSTEMS THAT MAKES
A LOT OF MONEY AND THEN ALSO.
WE WANT TO ENSURE TAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT TRANSPARENCY SO IN
ENCOURAGING THE CREATION OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTION AT THE
WATERBOARD WE REALLY TRIED TO
BUILD IN AS MUCH TRANSPARENCY AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU WERE IN ADMINISTRATORS THE
LAST THING YOU WANT TO DO LIKE
THINK ABOUT.
YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICT GOING
BANKRUPT AND HAVING
ADMINISTRATOR POINTED IT'S NOT
WHAT ANYBODY WANTS IN SOME OF
THESE WATER SYSTEMS.
DON'T NEED AN ADMINISTRATOR THEY
NEED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS
VERY CLEAR AND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATOR FUNCTION.
HAD THAT THAT THE BOARD HAS MORE --
ABILITY TO DETERMINE WHEN THAT
ADMINISTRATOR FUNCTION IS
APPROPRIATE.
AND BY WE HAVE OTHER ISSUES BUT
WE CAN TALK TO THE AUTHOR ABOUT
THAT AND WE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
MA'AM FOR A GROUP OF YOUR
TESTIMONY WOULD NOW LIKE TO
WELCOME THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE
FIRST AND LASSEN ORGANIZATION
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JONATHAN NELSON WITH THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER WE HAVE
AN AND POSE UNLESS THE MINUTE
POSITION.
ON THE BILL BUT OUR VERY GREAT
FONG RESPECTFUL FOR THE SENATORS
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE WE ALSO
WORK IN YOUR DISTRICT AND AS WE
BOTH NOW.
WE HAVE WORK TO DO SO WE LOOK
FOR TO ROLLING UP OUR SLEEVES ON
THIS WITH YOU AT THE SESSION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SIR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
BUYING ACOSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION AND SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES.
ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS A MINUTE BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AS A BILL CONTINUES
TO MOVE THANK HIM THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR WE'RE GRATEFUL.
GLASCOFF THOSE MAY BE POSTED
COULD PLEASE ADVANCED MICROPHONE
THIS TIME LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSED.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE TO BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE
RECEIVED ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE ALSO WOULD WORK ON
THE MOTION.
THE MOTION I CENTER TARA WE DO
HAVE A QUESTION BY A CENTER
ABOUT CENTERVILLE.
I I I I I I AGREE WITH THE BILL
OKAY BUT I HAVE A QUESTION -- IT
RELATES TO A PARTICULAR
SITUATION FOR MY DISTRICT MY
DISTRICT HAS.
ESSENTIALLY WATER PROVIDED BY A
PRIVATE WATER COMPANY.
AND THERE'S ALSO -- OF SMALL
WATER COMPANIES.
AND IF SO HAPPENS THAT OF SMALL
WATER COMPANIES BECOME NOT NON
COMPLIANT.
HOW DOES THIS AFFECT
[inaudible]
THAT SITUATION.
WHEN -- SURROUNDING WATER
COMPANY MIGHT BE SOME BIG.
COMPANY THERE'S A KIND OF
PRESENT US WITH A CASE WERE WERE
FORCING A SMALL WATER COMPANY.
TO JOIN THE BIG WATER COMPANY OR
HOW DOES HOW DOES IS SO AFFECT
THAT SITUATION.
PRIVATE CALL IS NOT THE PUBLIC
WATER.
THE PRIVATE COMPANIES.
WHERE WE HAVE THIS BIG COMPANY
THE BIGGEST ONE IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY?
SAN JOSE WATER WATER COMPANY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
SENATOR THAT THE THE STRATEGY
THAT WERE USING IN THIS BILL.
IS IS.
TO TAKE CARE OF CHRONICALLY NON
COMPLIANT WATER SYSTEMS THAT
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
IMPROVEMENTS -- AND THAT UP OVER
THE YEARS HAVE JUST NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
THERE HAVE BEEN CONSOLIDATIONS
IT BEEN VOLUNTARY AND SOME THAT
HAVE WORKED OUT VERY WELL -- IN
AND WE'RE NOT TOUCHING THAT
PROCESS AT ALL WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS THAT FOR THESE NON
CHRONICALLY NON COMPLIANT.
SYSTEMS WHERE THERE IS NOT A
LARGE WATER SYSTEM NEXT TO THEM
THAT THEY CAN BE -- CONSOLIDATED
WITH THAT THERE THERE NEEDS TO
BE AN ALTERNATIVE AND THIS WOULD
GIVE.
THE ALTERNATIVE IS TO ALLOW A
NUMBER OF THESE TO JOIN TOGETHER
FOR A KIND OF MEANS OF SCALE
ACCESS RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AT STATE SO IN THE IN
THE INSTANCE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THEY WOULD NOT BE FORCED --
UNLESS THEY THEY ARE THEY
CONTINUE TO BE CHRONICALLY A NON
COMPLIANT IN THE STATE WATER
BOARD CANNOT GET THEM TO DO WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO.
WELL.
I AM A WORM ABOUT IS OPEN -- WE
HAVE ALL THESE OLD.
PROBABLY NON COMPLIANT.
WATER SYSTEMS UP IN THE
MOUNTAINS.
SACRAMENTO NEWS READ WITH THE
STATE'S THAT DRIVER YOU KNOW THE
AREA.
SO THEIR ADJACENT TO SAN JOSE
WATER COMPANY [inaudible]
BUT THERE.
I THINK ONE ONE BANKRUPT -- A
FEW YEARS AGO -- HOW DOES IT
AFFECT THOSE KINDS OF SMALL
MOUNTAIN?
WATER COMPANIES LIKE DUNN.
THE SITUATION I'M TALKING ABOUT
YEAH I THINK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION -- IT ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
LIKE IT'S REDUCING SO YEAH OF
COURSE I'M SORRY DANIEL BUSTED
HAD WITH CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION -- AND IN
IN THOSE SITUATIONS YOU KNOW THE
THERE'S AN ADMINISTRATOR THAT'S
GOING TO BE APPOINTED TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION WOULD BE
FOR THE SYSTEMS.
SO IT MIGHT BE THE SOLUTIONS
RECIPE FOR FOURTEEN WHICH WE
THINK YOU KNOW BRIDGES AN
IMPORTANT GAP.
BUT IT ALSO MIGHT BE THROUGH
EXISTING AUTHORITY THAT THE
STATE BOARD HAS -- SO IT JUST
YOU KNOW IT REALLY OFFERS AT
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX AND THERE
MAY BE.
ANOTHER SOLUTION THAT IS A MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR THOSE SYSTEMS
OKAY OKAY I THINK THAT ANSWERS
MY QUESTION.
I THANK YOU I'M A SUPPORT THE
BILL AND JUST AS A WHERE FOR
THAT FRONT BECAUSE MOST OF THE
WE'RE WE'RE VERY UNIQUE AND
UNUSUAL IN OUR COUNTY THAT MOST
OF THE WATERS PROVIDED BY SIMPLY
A PRIVATE.
WE DON'T HAVE.
PUBLIC WATER IN. TOO MUCH IS
SACKLER COUNTY SOME SOME CITIES
DAILY SACRIFICE SANTA CLARA AND
FOLLOW UP TO DO BUT THE THE REST
OF US ARE.
PRIVATE WATER COMPANIES YEAH AND
WHILE THIS IS A POINT IN TIME
WHERE YOU KNOW THERE'S A CERTAIN
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA TO BE PART
OF THIS BILL.
IN THE FUTURE IF THERE'S A
SYSTEM THAT BECOMES NON
COMPLIANT -- YOU KNOW THE STATE
FOUR DOES HAVE EXISTING
AUTHORITIES A LAUGH GO YOU KNOW
HAS A PROCESS AND SO THOSE COULD
POTENTIALLY BE MERGED AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CENTER UP
BEFORE WE CONTINUE WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AS ONE
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE CLARIFYING
WITHIN THEM AND STARTED A WE'RE
GONNA BE CLARIFYING THAT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD WILL.
EVALUATE ALL OPTIONS PROTECTING
DRINKING WATER INCLUDING
CONSOLIDATION RECEIVERSHIP
INFORMATION OF A SMALL SYSTEM
WATER AUTHORITY WHICHEVER IS THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE IN
PROTECTIVE OF DRINKING WATER
SOURCES.
AT THAT IT THOSE ARE THE MOMENTS
THAT WILL BE TAKING HERE TODAY.
AND WILL BE TAKEN UP AN
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
WHICH IS THE NEXT POLICY
COMMITTEE AFTER GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
THAT GO TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
FORCING HER CAREER AT THIS
MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE A MOTION TO
BE ABLE TO APPROVE SP.
FOUR FOURTEEN WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR BELL THIS IS A DO
PASSED TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
THOSE AMENDMENTS ONCE AGAIN WILL
BE TAKEN UP IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE.
THEIR CAREER ON TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR EFFORTS --
AND WOULD LIKE TO BE AT OFFER
CLOSING STATEMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE ALL OVER
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND TO
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANOTHER TOOL IS REALLY IMPORTANT
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MAN SENATOR VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR EFFORTS
MISSING JUST A FEW COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WIDER HI MCGUIRE
I'M MORE LOCK.
OR LIKE AYE BELL.
WELL I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
WELL I NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
HEY CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE MAN CENTER WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN ALLOW FOLKS TO BE
OUT AT ON THE NETWORK COULD YOU
SEE MA'AM.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE
WELCOMING SENATOR JONES.
ON SB SIX SIX THREE FOCUSING ON
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION FOR
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS.
AS WE START GETTING SET UP FOR
CENTER JONES WE BY TAKE A MOMENT
THE WELCOME.
OUR STATE TREASURER HERE OR DO
YOU IS HERE TODAY.
WELCOME TO UNIMODULAR THE
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE HER --
HOLDING TIGHT IN WAITING WITH US
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR MOM FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKELY TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR
JONES.
WELCOME SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE HERE PRESENTING MY
FIRST SENATE BILL.
NOT MUCH NOT MUCH I NOT MY FIRST
ONE OUT OF COMMITTEE I ACTUALLY
HAD ONE ON CONSENT YESTERDAY SO --
BUT IT IS AN HONOR TO HAVE.
HONOR TO HAVE MY FIRST
PRESENTATION HERE WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING.
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY THREE SIX
SIXTY THREE PROVIDES A PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION FOR PROPERTY OWNED
BY A VETERAN ORGANIZATION.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS A WELFARE
EXEMPTION FOR PROPERTY TAXES FOR
NON PROFITS SUCH AS RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS HOSPITALS AND
VETERAN ORGANIZATIONS.
HOWEVER THIS EXEMPTION ONLY
APPLIES TO PORTIONS OF THE
PROPERTY USE EXCLUSIVELY FOR
CHARITABLE PURPOSES SUCH AS
ROOMS USED FOR COUNSELING
SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND THE
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION TO ALL
PARTS OF THE PROPERTY EXCEPT FOR
THE ACTUAL BAR. FOR ALCOHOL
SERVING AREA.
SB SIX SIXTY THREE WILL PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO VETERANS HALLS THAT
ARE TRYING TO ENHANCE THE SOCIAL
WELFARE WELFARE.
OF CURRENT AND FORMER MILITARY
PERSONNEL.
THIS BILL IS IDENTICAL TO A BILL
THAT DOES SOME WOMEN ADAM GRAY --
GOT PASSED LAST YEAR AND HE'S
ALSO THE PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR --
WHICH PAY PASS IN ACTUALLY
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY FROM BOTH
HOUSES YET WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN.
I WITH ME TODAY IS SET THREE
BOMB BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
LEGION.
AND ASSESSOR RECORDER CLERK FROM
SAN DIEGO ERNIE DRAWN AND BERG --
REPRESENTING THE ASSESSORS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
REED AND THE GOOD GENTLEMAN FROM
SAN DIEGO OR WE WELCOME BACK TO
THE COMEDIAN AS WE ALWAYS SAY
THE MAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND SO --
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU SIR THIS
THREE LEVEL.
HEY THERE YOU GO I DAY.
PLEASE HISTORY MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET THREE BUT
THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM OF
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA.
AMVETS DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF TWENTY TWO VETERAN
ORGANIZATIONS.
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE VIETNAM VETERANS
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL.
MY I IT WAS A ARMY INFANTRY FOR
FIVE YEARS FROM 200-042-2000
NINE WITH TWO COMBAT TOURS. TO
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN.
I'D LIKE.
TO JUST GIVE A LITTLE OVERVIEW
OF OF MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE
AMERICAN LEGION -- BY MY POST
AMERICAN LEGION POST ONE
NINETEEN AND PLACERVILLE.
BOB DOES A LOT OF DONATIONS AND
WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY --
RECENTLY THERE WAS A NEW BOYS
AND GIRLS.
CLUB -- ESTABLISHED AND THE
AMERICAN LEGION DONATED.
THE FLAG POLE AND THE LIGHTING.
WHICH WAS OVER TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS THEY ALSO WORK WITH THE
VETERANS IN THE COMMUNITY --
HELPING WITH FINANCIAL THINGS --
DELIVERY WOULD GETTING WHAT --
THE ELDERLY FOLKS -- THESE POSTS
PROVIDE A GREAT VALUE TO THE
COMMUNITY IN THE VETERANS --
THEY'RE ABLE TO CONNECT WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND SHARE EXPERIENCES.
FROM.
COMBAT OR MILITARY SERVICE --
AND WERE ABLE TO CONNECT TO ONE
ANOTHER TO OTHER SERVICES THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
BENEFICIAL -- THIS TAX RELIEF
WOULD HELP.
TO AID OTHER VETERANS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND ALSO GIVE BACK
MORE TO THE COMMUNITY.
WITHIN THESE POSTS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME IT IS MUCH THREE GEN
WORKFORCE OR SIR GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU ERNIE DREIBERG SAYS
YOU'RE SAYING YOU GO COUNTY AND
REPRESENTING THE SISTERS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THIS BILL WILL SIMPLIFY THIS
PROCESS RIGHT NOW THE EXEMPTION
WAS -- DESIGNED.
I THINK IT'S A EVEN OLDER I AM I
IT GOES WAY BACK.
AND HE HAD.
TO AT THAT POINT IN TIME THEY
STARTED TO MAKE THESE AREAS.
X. TAX MORE IN THESE AREAS
EXEMPTION.
IT'S REALLY JUST ADDED
COMPLEXITY TO OUR JOBS WE HAVE
TO GO IN AND SQUARE OFF WE HAVE
TO WATCH WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
CHAIR.
THIS WOULD MAKE IT REALLY SIMPLE
AND IT'S A SOMETHING THAT ALL
THESE ASSESSORS SUPPORT.
AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FEARING
FOR SERVICEMEN I WOULD LIKE WE
ARE OPENING UP. TO ANYONE WHO'S
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD ON SB
SIX SIX THREE SB SIX SIX THREE
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF THE COMPLETE
ADVANCE THE MICROPHONE THIS TIME.
YOU SEE NOW WE NOW LIKE TO TURN
OVER THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS
TIME.
HEARING SEE NO OPPOSITION
WITHOUT RICHARD OVER THE
COMMITTEE TO BE RECEIVING ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL
ON THE FLOOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS LAST CALL FROM
COMMITTEE HEARING SENIOR CENTER
JONES REJECT CLOSER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT THESE
VETERANS HALLS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
AND THEY WILL BE ABLE TO BETTER
SERVE OUR VETERAN POPULATION IF
THEY CAN FULLY YOU'LL FOR YOU
YOU UTILIZE THIS WELFARE
EXEMPTION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS MORNING AND WELCOME
YOUR CO AUTHORSHIP THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- MISTER SENATOR MITCH
CENTER I WANT TO JUST CONFIRM
YOUR TO BE TAKEN THOSE TECHNICAL
IN THE MEN'S -- AS WE'VE WORKED
OUT RIGHT YES ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH INTEREST AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER BELL THIS
HAS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
VETERANS AFFAIRS.
IS LANE CHESAPEAKE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WIRE HI.
I'M MORE LOCK.
BELL BILL I HERTZBERG FOR CATTLE.
YOUR TOTAL I'D NIELSEN.
WIENER.
WIENER I'D LUCY I CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR EIGHT ZERO VOTE --
MISTER CENTER WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AND THEN
WE'LL ADD FOLKS ON AS THEY COME
IN COMMITTEE THERE IS SHERMAN
APPRECIATE AND EVERYBODY SUPPORT
TAKE ICE WORKCENTRE JONES THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
MEMBERS IF IT WORKS FOR FOLKS --
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE.
GOING IN FILE ORDER WE LIKE TO
BE TO GO -- TO AB.
ONE FORTY SEVEN AB ONE FORTY
SEVEN I'M GONNA BE JOINING THE
CHAIR WOMAN -- FROM THE SIMPLY
THERE ALONG WITH A TREASURE
HUNTER TURNED THE GAVEL OVER TO
SENATOR BATTLE IS WE DO NOT OVER
SENIOR AND NIELSEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BE ABLE [inaudible]
TO NO I'M.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO I I
HAVE. TO THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
FOR A MOMENT -- YEAH.
THE ONE CHIRLA MEETING ON THIS
LITTLE [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
WE HAVE [inaudible]
THURMOND AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE.
WITH.
AB ONE FOUR SEVEN THIS MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- AND I'M
GONNA TAKE A MOMENT -- MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND NEIGHBORS A
COMMUNITY AND I THINK THE
INDIVIDUAL TO MY LEFT AT
CHAIRWOMAN BURKE FROM THE
ASSEMBLYSHE'S BEEN.
AN INCREDIBLE PARTNER ON A
COMPLICATED BILL -- AND I WANNA
SAY THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BURKE AS WELL AS HER INCREDIBLE
TEAM UP FOR ALL THE EFFORTS AND
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
THINK THE INDIVIDUAL TO MY RIGHT --
WE ON THE OR IS A TREASURE OF
THE CITY CALIFORNIA AND I WANT
TO SAY ON BEHALF OF A CHAIRMAN
BURKE AND MYSELF HOW GRATEFUL WE
WERE TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
YEAH I KNOW WE HAVE MORE WORK TO
GO.
BUT JUST THINK YOU SO MUCH
TREASURE MY FOR YOUR WONDERFUL%
EFFORTS AS WELL.
BUT THIS IS A BEEN A TEAM EFFORT
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE ON AB ONE
FORTY SEVEN WHICH AND IMPLEMENTS
THE WAY FAIR DECISION FROM THE
SUPREME COURT IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A WELL THOUGHT OUT IN
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH THE WAY
FOR DECISION IS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT US SUPREME COURT
DECISIONS IN DECADES BECAUSE IT
REMOVES THE COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE ONLINE.
AN ATA STATE BUSINESSES WHO DO
DIDN'T WHO HISTORICALLY NOT
COLLECTED SALES TAX.
IT REMOVES THAT ADVANTAGE OVER
BRICK AND MORTAR CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS WHO'VE ALWAYS
COLLECTED TAXES THIS INEQUITY
CAN GIVE A BIG EDGE FOR ABOUT
SEVEN POINT 25% TO MORE THAN 10%.
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU LIVE IN
THE STATE. TO ADDRESS A
COMPANIES AN ONLINE RETAILERS.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIRTY
THREE STATES HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED THE COURT DECISION
AND EVERY OTHER STATE WITH THE
SALES TAX IS EXPECTED TO FOLLOW
SUIT.
IN AB ONE FORTY SEVEN DOES THE
SAME HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE.
THE MEASURE WILL ALSO INCREASE
STATE AND LOCAL REVENUES BY MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AFTER THE FIRST
YEAR.
MANY OF THESE OCAL REVENUES ARE
DEDICATED TO LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL.
THIS BILL STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ONLINE
PLATFORMS AT A STATE BUSINESSES
AND MANY OTHERS.
AND WE'RE PLEASE HAVE SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WILL BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT TODAY AND
AGAIN I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE STATE
TREASURER WHO'S.
BEEN A 1100% PARTNER IN THIS AND
I COULD TURN OVER MISTER CHAIR
THE FLOOR TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE -- THE BILL TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN INTO TREASURE AND
GAIN SOME WOMAN THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU AS GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AND I I TOO WOULD LIKE
TO THINK CENTER MCGUIRE AND THE
CHAIR AND TREASURER FOR UNIMOG
THIS HAS ACTUALLY BEEN.
AGREED EXPERIENCE WE'VE ALL
WORKED VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER AND
I THINK THE POLICY REPRESENTS --
THE COLLABORATION QUITE WELL --
BUT AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
ALONG WITH MY CO AUTHOR.
AS THE TEARS EXPLAIN THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A COMPREHENSIVE AND
BALANCED SET OF POST WAY FAIR
TAX COLLECTION COLLECTION RULES
THAT MAKES SENSE FOR THE
CONSUMER.
SMALL BUSINESS AND THE STATE.
AB ONE FORTY SEVEN DOES SO IN
THREE WAYS FIRST IT PROVIDES
RELIEF TO SMALL BUSINESS BY
INCREASING THE ECONOMIC NEXUS
THRESHOLD FROM 1-001-000-2500
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ELIMINATING
THE TWO HUNDRED OR MORE SEPARATE
TRANSACTION THRESHOLD ENTIRELY.
SECOND AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
RECOGNIZES THE REALITIES OF
TODAY'S ECONOMIST EIGHT COMMERCE
A CONNIE BY REQUIRING ONLINE
MARKETPLACES TO CLICK SALES TAX
SALES AND USE TAX ON BEHALF OF
THEIR THIRD PARTY RETAILERS.
FINALLY AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
PROMOTES CLARITY AND SIMPLICITY.
BY REQUIRING RETAILERS TO
COLLECT AND REMIT LOCAL DISTRICT
TAXES ONCE THEY SELL OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA.
ELIMINATING THE BURDEN SOME
REQUIREMENT TO TRACK SALES IN
EACH DISTRICT.
OUT WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
AND I'VE HANDED OFF TO TRY TO
REPORT WE HAVE TREASURER LAW YES
I MET HIM MISTER BUSH I DO MOVE
THE BILL.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION.
GO AHEAD TREASURER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE.
OF THE STRONG PARTNERSHIP OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BURKE ON THIS -- VERY --
COMPLICATED BUT PRESSING ISSUE
FACING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I SERVED ON THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION FROM.
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND THIS HAS BEEN --
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES FACING
THE AGENCY IS HOW.
TO CREATE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR THE BRICK AND MORTAR
BUSINESSES THAT ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
PURSES THOSE ONLINE RETAILERS ON
THE WAY FAIR DECISION --
CODIFIED OF THE DECISION WHICH
LEADS US HERE -- TODAY AND I'M
VERY HAPPY THAT THERE ARE MANY
OF SUPPORTERS.
WHO ARE?
GOING -- TO YOU KNOW MAKE THIS
OP CODIFIED THE WAY FOR DECISION
AND FINALLY BRING SOME.
TAX REVENUES ARE.
NEEDED AND REQUIRE TAX REVENUES
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED HERE.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
DAN YOU'RE GONNA BE AWFULLY A
CALIFORNIA CITIES APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE AUTHORS AS WELL AS
THE TREASURER OF THE SPONSOR AND
OTHERS A GREAT BILL AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARTY TO
CASTING AND I MIGHT I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF ONLINE
MARKETPLACE -- CLIENTS THAT I
HAVE.
I WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE SENATOR
MCGUIRE I WANT TO DO OF COURSE
ALSO THANK STATE TREASURER FIONA
Mà WHO HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS BATTLE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME -- I I HAVE TO
SAY THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
COMMENDABLE EFFORT ON A VERY
VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE.
WE ARE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR
THE ATTENTION THAT EVERYBODY HAS
GIVEN TO THIS.
AND THE URGENCY WITH WHICH THEY
HAVE ACTED IN MOVING COUNTLESS
COUNTLESS ONLINE BUSINESSES WHO
ARE NOW.
IN THE WAKE OF THE WAY FOR
DECISION AND IN THE WAKE OF THE
UNCERTAINTY SURROUNDING HOW
ONLINE MARKETPLACES ARE BEING
TREATED IN WHO HAS THE
COLLECTION BURDEN.
A LOT OF THESE BUSINESSES ARE
NOW A GOING TO BE RELIEVED OF
THE ONEROUS BURDEN THAT HAS
ARISEN AS A RESULT OF THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN EMERGING
ONLINE TECHNOLOGIES.
AND AT THE SALES TAX CODE WHICH
NEEDS TO BE UPDATED SO AGAIN
THANK YOU TO STAFF AS WELL THANK
YOU TO STAFF ON ON BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE SIDE FOR
THIS INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLE
EFFORT AND SUCH A COMPACT PERIOD
OF TIME THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR
MISTER CHAIRS THAT TREASURER Mà
WANT TO THANK ALL ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS -- MARKER PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF THE ONLINE MERCHANT
SKILL AND WE ARE IN WHOLE
HEARTED SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS
MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN SUPPORT.
RENDON RYAN WITH ME SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
A STEVE AUTOGRAPH THE NAPA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
THIS NUMBER AND EVERY REAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
TEACHER MEMBERS DOMINICK
TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF OF BEST
BUY WHICH IS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION --
WE'RE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WE THANK THE AUTHORS AND
TREASURE Mà FOR YOUR EFFORTS ON
THIS.
A MEASURE AND ONE OF THE MORE
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF THIS BILL
AT LEAST FROM MY CLIENTS
PERSPECTIVE.
IS THE HAVING IMPLEMENTATION
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER AS IT
LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
THEM COMING THE NEXT HOLIDAY
SEASON SO -- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THIS AND WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR STACEY DOLLY
ON BEHALF OF TARGET AND A HOME
DEPOT AND I WOULD ECHO DON'S
ELOQUENT -- COMMENTS AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS
VERY APPRECIATED.
REBECCA MARCUS ON BEHALF OF HDL
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE IN THE ONE
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CENTER HERTZBERG [inaudible]
ON WHY THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR THRESHOLD AND WHY NOT THE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
THRESHOLD.
AS SET FORTH IN THE SUPREME
COURT CASE WE KNOW THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE TO COLLECT
TAXES AND THIS HUNDRED THOUSAND
JUST IN CALIFORNIA JIM ABUSES
DURING A MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
BERMAN HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW A WHY NOT BE
THAT WE CAN ANALYSIS IS
DETERMINE WHAT THE DELTA IS
BETWEEN A HUNDRED THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH
ISREVENUE LOSS BECAUSE SEE WE
KNOW THE TECHNOLOGICALLY ANYBODY
IN BUSINESS TODAY.
CAN SIMPLY DOWNLOAD WHICH TAX
JAR SO MANY OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
WOULD YOU CAN CALCULATE A SALES
TAX FROM ALL FIFTY STATES BILLS
BILLS TAX ON GOODS AND SERVICES.
JUST IN CASE SOMEONE'S LISTENING
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE. TO DO AND
REALLY INEXPENSIVE TO DO AND SO
MY QUESTION IS WHAT WHATWHY
LIMITED UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN SOMEBODY WHO
HAS A BUSINESS WITH A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA COULD BE A
SUBSTANTIAL BUSINESS AS EASY TO
COMPLY.
WE DID WE WE STARTED RESEARCH ON
THIS LAST AUGUST AND WHAT WE
FOUND WAS IN CONJUNCTION WITH CD
TFA WAS THAT THE THREAT THE
AMOUNT OF INCOME THAT WE WOULD
SEE IT AS A STATE BETWEEN A
HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WAS VERY CLOSE TO IF
NOT EQUAL TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE.
COSTS THAT IT WOULD TO TO FOLLOW
UP ON THAT THAT THOSE NUMBERS OF
BUSINESSES AND SO AS AS BOTH CD
TFA AND AS ALL OF US REVIEW
THOSE NUMBERS WE DECIDED THAT TO
SIMPLIFY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND TO ALSO.
BECAUSE THE REVENUE OF ONCE WAS
SO NEGLIGIBLE THAT THAT IT WAS
NOT WORTH DOING IT IT DOESN'T
SOUND LOGICAL TO ME I CANNOT
BELIEVE.
THAT EVEN IF YOU DIDN'T USE AN
IMPLEMENTATION TOOL IT SOUNDS
POLITICAL I GET IT BUT IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO ME EVEN IF YOU.
HE SAID TO THE AGENCY ARE NOT
GOING TO DO IT AND NOT SPEND ANY
MONEY ON COLLECTION SOMEBODY'S
GOING TO PAY THE TAX.
AND THAT'S NEW DOLLARS IT IT
MAKES NO SENSE TO ME THAT THE
AGENCY WOULD I I WOULD HAVE COST
QUESTION THAT CONCLUSION.
IF YOU CAN TELL ME THAT WILL
TURN IT OVER -- TO MISS PEEL
CIRCUS PEOPLE SOCCER IS THE
DIRECTOR LEGISLATION FOR THE
CALVET APARTMENT TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT.
TO SAY THANK YOU I TO THEM AS
THEY HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
THIS THE DELTA -- THAT -- THE
SENATORS TALK ABOUT AS OF
APPROXIMATELY IN THIS BILL
CIRCLE CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
ABOUT EIGHT TO TEN MILLION -- ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS -- THAT'S REALLY
A APPROXIMATE ALL THIS STATE.
WOULD NOT SEE COMING INTO THE
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE OUR MARKET
IS SO SATURATED WITH LARGER
ONLINE RETAILERS FRATERNAL
REPEAL STICKER TO BE ABLE TO
CLARIFY -- ANY MISTAKE THAT I
MAY JUST MAKE.
I GUESS YOU'RE VERY CLOSE -- IT
IT SAID TWELVE TO FIFTEEN
MILLION ON AN ANNUAL BASIS HOW
DID YOU COME WITH A NUMBER.
HOW DID -- WE BECAUSE YOU GOT
THE HATCHERIES TO COME WITH A
NUMBER -- WE LOOKED AT THE
UNIVERSE OF COMPANIES THAT WOULD
FALL IN BETWEEN THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD BASED
ON CENSUS DATA.
IF YOU COULD AT SOME POINT A MAP
YEAH I JUST LIKE TO KNOW JUST.
CURIOUS TO ME I MEAN I KNOW
CERTAIN COMPANIES LIKE AMAZON
THE LIKE CERTAINLY CONTRACT WITH
A LOT OF COMPANIES AND UTILIZE
THE AMAZON TOOL IT'S ONE OF THE
BIG ISSUES AND ON PRIVACY IN
SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS WERE
INVOLVED IN. TO ACTUALLY --
PROMOTE SALES BUT I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE I'M
JUST TELLING YOU INTUITIVELY IT
MAKE AND IT'S IN THE ECONOMY OF
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THAT IS BEING INFORMED IN
DRAMATIC WAYS BY THE INTERNET
IT'S SHOCKING TO ME.
THAT BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS ANYTHING LESS THAN A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I CAN
SPEAK TO THAT FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD.
BE HAPPY TO SHARE TO SHARE THE
DATA WILL GET IT TAKEN -- BUT
SECONDLY -- INTERNET SALES ARE
HIGHLY CONCENTRATED AND LARGE
COMPANIES RIGHT SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF COMPANIES
THAT ARE ABOVE THAT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT BETWEEN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
THERE'S JUST NOT A HUGE.
DIFFERENCE LOOK AT HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT ESTIMATE WITH THE I.
WHY WAS THAT IN THE LAST
QUESTION IS WHY WAS THAT BY
IMPLEMENTATION DATE PUSHED BACK
ON THE REST THE COUNTRY'S
IMPLEMENTING IT.
ON THE EARLIER DATE [inaudible]
THE WORLD.
SO A FEW ITEMS -- WE'VE BEEN IN
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION -- WAY
CITY TFA THE REASON WHY -- WE
ARE LOOKING AT A BIT OF A DELAY --
BUT MAKING SURE THAT IT IS
IMPLEMENTED PRIOR TO THE
HOLIDAYS.
IS TO ALLOW PLATFORMS IN THE
LARGEST ONLINE MARKETPLACE IN
THE WORLD TO BE ABLE TO ADAPT --
IN IT IS TAKING A BIT LONGER I
EVEN THOUGH WE SEEN THIRTY THREE
STATES ADAPT JUST BECAUSE THE
COMPLEXITY OF A MARKET PLACE.
AND WHERE WE HAVE BEEN ADAMANT
IN ALL TURN OVER THE CHAIRWOMAN
IS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HIT THAT THE HOLIDAY
NUMBER ONE IT'S EQUITY WITH --
BRICK AND MORTAR RETAILERS.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT VERTICALLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES THAT
<c.green>ENEFIT EVERYDAY CALIFORNIANS</c>
WILL BE -- TO CAPTURE THOSE
DOLLARS MEDICARE ISSUE IN FRONT
OF HOUSING EQUITY MISTER
CHAIRMAN WITH BRICK AND MORTAR
RETAILERS ARE CURRENTLY PAYING
THE SALES TAX RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE GIVEN THIS GOT THE
EVERYBODY ONLINE ABILITY NOT TO
PAY THE SALES TAX NOT JUST THE
REVENUE FROM THE STATE.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
IN BRICK AND MORTAR AND ONLINE
PEOPLE THE ONLINE PEOPLE AREN'T
PAYING IT YOU'RE DEALING THEIR
OBLIGATION TO PAY.
EQUITY WOULD MEAN THAT THEY
WOULD BE TREATED EQUALLY.
AND WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT --
WE HAVE BEEN IN CONSERVATION
OCCASION WITH THE RETAILERS WHO
REPRESENT ON NINE EXCUSE ME
THERE WAS A BRICK AND MORTAR --
THIS IS BEEN ABLE TO THERE HAVE
BEEN CHALLENGES AND ALL SITES
JUST BEING VERY HONEST ABOUT YOU
KNOW A VERY COMPLICATED TO BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT -- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE LANDED IN A
SWEET SPOT -- WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO CAPTURE THE BULK
OF THE REVENUE?
CENTERS FOR EXACTLY RIGHT ARE WE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CAPTURE THAT%
BETWEEN NOW.
AND OCTOBER NO IN CALIFORNIA AS
WE ALWAYS HERE'S A BIT DIFFERENT
IN BECAUSE OF OUR SIZE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME CHALLENGES
TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
SEVEN CHAIR ANYTHING THAT I
MISSED AND I THINK THE OTHER
THING IS SOME MARKET.
PLACE FACILITATORS ARE STILL IN
PROCESS OF COLLECTING THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED AND
WHICH TAXABLE PRODUCTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT AND SO.
WE DID WE WE TRIED TO FIND THE
SWEET SPOT WHERE -- WE WHERE WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE RAMP UP ON
RESPONSIBILITY BUT WE GAVE IT A
DEADLINE DATE ON'T AS TO WHEN.
WE WOULD START COLLECTING YEAH
MY MY ONLY POINT CLOSE ON THIS
IS JUST.
YOU KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW THIS UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT CASE IT CAME DOWN
THE SAME DAY FOR ALL FIFTY
STATES.
A LOT OF OTHER STATES THAT WE
KNOW WE LOOK AT AND WE SEEMS TO
ME THAT WE NEED.
TO ALWAYS ASK OURSELVES THE
HONEST QUESTIONS AMONG FRIENDS
WHY ARE WE WHY IS OUR STANDARD
DIFFERENT THAN EVERYBODY ELSE'S
NOT JUST SIZE WHY IS THAT THE
CASE WHY CAN THEY IMPLEMENT WHAT
IS THE DIFFERENCE.
HOW DO WE ANSWER THAT QUESTION I
THINK WE HAVE THAT OBLIGATION IN?
JUST BEING HONEST BROKERS OF
PUBLIC POLICY.
AND TO THAT ED TO THAT EFFECT I
DON'T I DON'T DISAGREE
NECESSARILY -- HOWEVER THEY WERE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL WHERE WE
DO HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
THE FACT THAT YES IN OTHER THIS
HAS BEEN PUT IN PLACE AND PEOPLE
SHOULD SHOULD IT HERE TO OUR TO
OUR STANDARD IMMEDIATELY --
HOWEVER I THINK WITH THE COURSE
OF HOW EASY IT IS AND HOW HARD
IT WAS TO ACTUALLY COLLECT THE
INFORMATION THEY HAD NOT FULLY
PREPARED SOME OF THEM.
IN THAT IN THE WAY THEY SHOULD
HAVE.
WE HAD TO MAKE BASIC DECISIONS
ON HOW WE WERE GOING TO GO ABOUT
AND DO THIS IN A WAY THAT WAS A
SEAMLESS IMPOSSIBLE BOTH FOR THE
STATE'S CD TFA AND FOR THE
RETAILERS.
AND AND AND MY CONCERN IS THAT A
C. T. OF A ANNOUNCED THAT
BEGINNING APRIL FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN RETAILER
LOCATED OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
MUST COLLECT USE TAX IF DURING
THE PROCEEDING OR CALENDAR YEAR.
THE RETAILER'S SALES IN THE
CALIFORNIA EXCEED HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND OR THE RETAILER
MADE SALES INTO CALIFORNIA IN
TWO HUNDRED OR MORE SEPARATE
TRANSACTIONS WHICH IS --
ACCORDING TO THE COURT CASE
HOWEVER APRIL FIRST WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET OUR BILL.
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK BY APRIL
FIRST I THINK WE WERE TRYING --
THAT WAS THE INTENTION -- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY -- BECAUSE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE NOT
GONNA MAKE ABLE FIRST DEADLINE I
HOPE THAT CD TFA ARE IN GOOD
FAITH IS GOING TO PUSH BACK.
ON SENDING THESE LETTERS --
BECAUSE IT IS VERY CONFUSING OUT
THERE IN THE MARKET PLACES WERE
CHINA.
YOU KNOW -- CREATE THE LAW
CODIFY IT AND SEE TFA IS SENDING
LETTERS ON THAT ARE YOU KNOW
FRANKLY -- UPSETTING FORTY
THOUSAND LEAST FORTY THOUSAND
AMAZON ONLINE MARKET PLACE UP
THERE PARTY PROVIDERS RIGHT NOW.
THIS LEFT OR RIGHT.
YOU ALWAYS DO SENATOR.
OUR QUESTIONS DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER ENQUIRIES OF MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY HEARING NONE THE TWO CHAIRS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE A CLOSER
CHAIRMAN MCGUIRE CARE WOMAN
BURKE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I HAD A MOTION
A MATURE JUST WANT EGGMAN TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR WOMAN THE
TREASURE -- IN HER OFFICE FOR
ALL THE WORK THEY'VE DONE IN
ALSO WANTED TO SAY KNOWLEDGE TO
OF THE CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE BEEN
ON THIS -- MISTER NOW MISTER
RUFF THEY'VE BEEN LIVING THE
DREAM ON THIS ISSUE -- FOR THE
MANY PART OF MUCH OF THE PAST
MANY MONTHS -- IS WAS A COVERED
A DEPARTMENT TEXAN TEAM
INSTRUCTION WHO HAD TO WORK WITH
THE SPENDING -- CHAIR.
I I REITERATE THE SAME THING THE
CHAIRMAN AND SAID THE STAFF HAS
BEEN AMAZING MY PARTNERS HAVE
BEEN FANTASTIC IT IS A VERY AS
AT CENTER HERTZBERG HAS SAID
IT'S BEEN A VERY COMPLICATED
ISSUE.
AND WE HAVE THREAD THE NEEDLE I
BELIEVE ON TO DELIVER SOME GOOD
POLICY FOR THE PEOPLE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
ON THE MOTIONS -- MEMBER WINNER
WE WOULD NOW CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
REQUIRE [inaudible]
MCGUIRE I MORE LOCK.
BELL.
BILL I HERTZBERG HI RICH
REGARDING HER TARA.
HELLO AYE NIELSEN AYE AYE IS AN
AYE WIENER.
WIENER I HAVE. SIX ZERO TWO ONE
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO SIX ZERO WE'RE
GOING OF ALL THE ROLE OFTEN TO
GET OTHER MEMBERS WHO ARE ABSENT
ON THE ROLE.
THIS CALL IS MOVED.
WE RETURNED TO THE CHAIR AND THE
GEN
.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE REMOVED
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWO
EIGHTY ONE WE HAVE SEVERAL FOLKS
WHO HAVE BEEN WAITING.
FOR QUITE SOME TIME I TO PRESENT
HERE TODAY THERE'S LARGE.
GROUP ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BILL
THIS IS IN RELY IN RELATION TO
THE CAL PALACES STORY.
WE'RE GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER
TO CENTER WIENER JUST AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND SOME OF THESE LARGER
BILLS WE LIKE ABOUT A LAY OUT
THE FORMAT TODAY -- INTO DAY FOR
TODAY WE'RE GONNA HAVE SENATOR
WIENER AS OUR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT BUT THEN GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO THE TREASURE.
AS WELL AS TO MR TO PLACES.
BY THEN WE'RE GONNA WELCOME UP
TO THREE INDIVIDUALS TO BE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
AND THEN OF COURSE HAVE ALL
SIDES PROVIDE A ME TOO FEW WILL
BOTH IN SUPPORT IS WELL IS ON AT
OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA GIVE IT
GIVE EACH SIDE EQUAL TIME.
OUR PRIMARY SPEAKER CENTER
WINNER IN WHO THE OPPOSITION
CHOOSES WHAT UNLIMITED TIME AND
WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER TO EACH OF
OUR SECONDARY SPEAKERS WHO WILL
HAVE UP TO FIVE MINUTES EACH.
I JUST SO WE ENSURE THERE'S
EQUAL TIME FOR ALL SIDES.
THEN WE ARE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
ON SB TWO EIGHTY ONE WELCOME SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT -- REALLY DEEPLY
THANK THE CHAIR AND IT'S STAFF
ARE FOR WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
OFFICE ON THE BILL -- AND
HELPING US MAKE IT INTO A BETTER
BILL WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT WE PREVIOUSLY MADE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL BASED ON
THE FEEDBACK -- AND WE ARE HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OR WERE
PRESENTED TO US IN WRITING --
RELATING -- TO THERE WERE THREE
AMENDMENTS AND WRITING WE'RE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THOSE INCLUDING
THE INTENT LANGUAGE TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT -- SB TWO EIGHTY ONE
CALLER JUST FUNDAMENTALLY A
LOCAL DISTRICT BILL THAT WOULD
DO TWO THINGS -- FOR ONCE AND
FOR ALL -- BASED ON DECADES OF
OVERWHELMING -- DESIRE BY OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY WILL BE ON THE
GUN SHOWS.
AT THE COW PALACE.
IT WILL ALSO CREATE A NEW LOCAL
AUTHORITY -- REFLECTING A LOCAL
COMMUNITY -- TO TAKE OVER
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE OF
THE CAL PALACE PROPERTY WHICH IS
ABOUT SIXTY EIGHT ACRES.
WHILE PLANNING FOR THE LIGHTS
FOR THE STATE'S FUTURE.
INCLUDING WHETHER TO CREATE
HOUSING AND MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT AT THE SIDE. TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY WILL MAKE THE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE FUTURE.
OF THE SITE.
CALLING THIS BILL DOES NOT JUST
COME OUT OF THIN AIR -- THIS
BILL COMES TO US AFTER DECADES.
OF OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
ATTEMPTING TO WORK WITH THE CAL
PALACE ON VARIOUS ISSUES -- AND
HITTING THEIR HEADS AGAINST THE
WALL OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN -- AN AGENCY THAT IS --
APPARENTLY UNWILLING TO
MEANINGFULLY WORK WITH THE LOCAL.
COMMUNITY. FIVE FOR DECADES WE
HAVE HAD UNANIMOUS VOTES AT THE
DALY CITY COUNCIL IN THE
CEMETERY - COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ASKING THE
CAL PALACE PALACE TO STOP
HOLDING GUN SHOWS AT THE SITE.
AND THE COW PALACE FOR DECADES
HAS COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY
IGNORED THAT LOCAL DESIRE -- I%
AM NOW THE THIRD SENATOR
REPRESENTING THIS AREA AFTER
JACKIE SPEAR AND MARK LENO -- TO
CARRY BILLS TO TRY TO GET THE
COW PALACE TO WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITY.
IN ADDITION FOR A LONG TIME DALY
CITY HAS BEEN ATTEMPTING TO WORK
WITH THE COW PALACE. TO MAKE
BETTER USE OF THE CALIPARI'S
LAMB THE CALIPARI'S IS THE
BUILDING WHICH PEOPLE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH WHICH IS IN VERY
POOR CONDITION AND IT'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF WORK
BUT IT IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
PARKING LOTS I'VE EVER SEEN IN
MY LIFE IT'S NOT JUST AN
AGRICULTURAL FAIR GROUNDS WE IT
IS A MEGA MASSIVE PARKING LOT IN
THE MIDDLE OF A RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITY.
THAT IS.
OVERWHELMINGLY NOT BEING USE
THERE ARE EVENTS THAT HAPPEN IN
THE CAL PALACE BUT LARGER AS
TIME NOTHING IS HAPPENING IN
THIS PARKING LOT AND CREATES
BLIGHT.
IN THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AND
DALY CITY HAS ATTEMPTED FOR
YEARS TO WORK WITH THE CAL
PALACE TO MAKE BETTER USE OF THE
LAND.
AND THE CAL PALACE HAS BEEN HELD
AT MOST PAID LIP SERVICE AND
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED -- SO IT'S
TIME TO MAKE CHANGE HERE WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE STATE NO WERE
WORSE THAN THE BAY AREA.
AND WE HAVE SIXTY ACRES OF LAND
JUST SITTING HERE THAT IS UNDER
UTILIZED IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
OUR LAND. TO THE BILL IN
ADDITION TO PERMANENTLY BANNING
THE GUN SHOWS WILL TRANSFER THE
LAND TO THIS LOCAL AGENCY --
WITH THE LIGHT THAT WILL BE
COMPRISED OF A BOARD OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS APPOINTED.
BY THE MAYOR OF SAN FRANCISCO BY
THE MAYOR OF DALY CITY I'M BY
THE CEMETERY COUNTY.
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS -- TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
ON MONDAY NIGHT AND AFTER THE
ANALYSIS CAME OUT BUT ON MONDAY
NIGHT THE DALY CITY COUNCIL
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL -- THE CEMETERY COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS NOT YET
ACTED BUT WE DO HAVE A LETTER OF
SUPPORT FROM SUPERVISOR DAVID
CAN ABOUT WHO REPRESENTS THIS
PORTION.
OF CEMETERY COUNTY SO ONCE AGAIN
THE LOCAL SUPPORT IS BROAD I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE
SIX OR SIX CO AUTHORS OF THIS
BILL -- EVERY SINGLE LEGISLATORS
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY WHO
REPRESENTS SAN FRANCISCO OR
CEMETERY COUNTY IS A CO AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL THIS IS NOT
CONTROVERSIAL LOCALLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY ODDS TESTIFY IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL OUR STATE
TREASURER FIONA Mà WHO USED TO
REBEL.
STILL REPRESENTS AREA BUT USED
TO REPRESENT -- THIS AREA IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY -- AND BUILT
LET'S SEE WHO IS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF DALY CITY THANK
YOU. FOR YOURMOTHER FOR SURE IS
YOUR FINANCING THANKS FOR
HANGING WITH US OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- I A REPRESENTED
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWELVE FROM
200-062-2000 TWELVE WHICH
INCLUDED.
A DALY CITY THE WEST SIDE OF SAN
FRANCISCO DALY CITY BROUGHT MRE
AND COMMA.
UP SO I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THE
COW PALACE OF VERY CLOSELY SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND
ESPECIALLY IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
WHEN.
GOVERNOR ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER
WANTED TO SELL OF THIS PIECE OF
PROPERTY -- THE CAP HOUSE WAS
BUILT AND DEVELOPED IN NINETEEN
FORTY ONE FOR THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF HOSTING THE GRAND
NATIONAL RODEO AND LIVESTOCK
SHOW.
SINCE THEN IS HOUSED IN MANY
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FAMILY
EVENTS SUCH AS THE CIRCUSES.
SWAP MEETS CAR SHOWS HOME AND
GARDEN SHOWS OTHER CONVENTIONS
BUT ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
WHICH IS ONE OF MY HUSBAND'S
FAVORITES THE DICKENS FAIR WE'VE
BEEN GOING FOR ABOUT ALMOST A
DECADE NOW AND IT IS ONE OF THE
PREMIER.
FAVORITE -- EVENTS THAT WE GO TO
SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT ON
THE RECORD BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF DICKENS FAIR.
FOLKS BACK THERE HOWEVER SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN A WHEN JOE
BARKAT.
LEFT AS GENERAL MANAGER -- ABLE
TWENTY THIRTEEN THE CAL HOW IS
BOARD AND MANAGEMENT HAVE FAILED
TO FOCUS ON SUSTAINING FAMILY
FRIENDLY ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE DANCE.
INSTEAD RELIED ON RENTING TO
VENDORS FOR REVENUE STEERING
AWAY FROM SUPPORTING THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES INTEREST.
IN TWENTY TWELVE FOR EXAMPLE --
THAT CAL POWERS BOARD SIGNED A
CONTRACT WITH ENTERPRISE RENT A
CAR.
UP WHERE FOR FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH ENTERPRISE A
USES A LOT OF THE PARKING SPOTS
AND REFURBISHES CARS FOR SALE.
IT WAS THE INTENTION AT THE TIME
AS I UNDERSTAND -- FROM -- THE
BOARD AND MANAGEMENT THAT --
THEY WOULD PUT MOST OF THE MONEY
TOWARD -- REFURBISHING THE FOUR
BIG BUILDINGS WHICH CANNOT BE
RENTED TODAY. 90% OF THE INDOOR
SPACE LEAKS TERRIBLY FROM THE
RAIN.
I IN.
THE WATER.
RUNS CONSISTENTLY THROUGH THE
YEAR AND ALSO ALL DAY AND NIGHT
I MEAN THIS IS JUST KIND OF A
LONG SHORT LIST OF THE THINGS
THAT NEEDED TO BE.
RENOVATED AND FIXED AND
MAINTAINED HOWEVER THE BOARD.
HAS DECIDED NOT -- TO PUT THE
MONEY TOWARD REFURBISHING THE
SITE BUT INSTEAD PUTTING IT
TOWARD OPERATIONS.
SO THROUGH MY EXPERIENCE -- I
BELIEVE THE COW PALACE BOARD AND
MANAGEMENT HAVE LOST ITS FOCUS
AND ALLOWED THE PROPERTY TO
DECLINE.
A WE DEFINITELY NEED LEAD NEW
LEADERSHIP AND A NEW PLAN FOR
THISHISTORIC PROPERTY.
THANK YOU IT IS MUCH BETTER
TREASURER NOT ENTER OVER MISS
MEMBER SHOULD A ****.
MR GERMAN SENATOR SENATORS BILL
DUPLICITY REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF DALY CITY.
UP FOR ANY OF YOU ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE GEOGRAPHY --
THE BAY SHORE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
DALY CITY IS SOMEWHAT ISOLATED
IN THAT THERE'S A MOUNTAIN
BETWEEN THE PRINCIPAL PART OF
THE CITY AND THE BAY SHORE
NEIGHBORHOOD DOMINATING THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD IS THE CAL PILES.
AND FOR DECADES AS SENATOR
WIENER POINTED OUT [inaudible]
THIS -- THIS NEIGHBORHOOD HAS
BEEN UNDER SERVED AND UNDER
UTILIZED AND BECAUSE OF THE
BLIGHTED -- CONDITION OF THE
AREA AS A RESULT OF THIS -- THE
THE THE RESIDENTS OF THE BASE
YOUR NEIGHBOR DON'T HAVE A
SUPERMARKET THERE THEY DON'T
HAVE A PHARMACY THERE.
AND THE I A PLUG A SENATOR
WINNERS EFFORTS TO ONCE AGAIN
BRING THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
WHICH IS NOT TROUBLING LOCALLY
AT ALL BUT CAN BE TROUBLING HERE
AT THE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL.
AND AND JUST TO ARTICULATE DALY
CITIES POSITION THAT SOMETHING
NEEDS TO ACTUALLY HAPPEN SO THAT
THE LOCALS -- LOCALLY ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THE COMMUNITY AT
LARGE IN THE DALY CITY AREA.
CAN MAKES A MEANINGFUL LAND USE
DECISIONS ON THIS PROPERTY.
AND CERTAINLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS EXCELLENT PIECE
LEGISLATION DALY CITY IS ALSO A-ON RECORD.
I THINK THE LAST THREE ATTEMPTS
TO BAN THE GUN SHOWS OF THE CAL
POWERS AND THEY ARE ONCE AGAIN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT ASPECT
OF THE BILL.
BECAUSE MISTER PERCY WE NOW
ELECTED A WELCOME ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME IN
ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IS THE AUTHOR
MENTION THE CITY COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO'S IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL OR DRY ABOUT THINKING
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS KEVIN PATTERSON --
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
THAT REPRESENT THE SAVE THE COW
PALACE COALITION MADE UP OF
THOUSANDS OF CURRENT USERS WHO
BELIEVE THE COW PALACE IS BOTH
VALUABLE AND VIABLE.
WE BELIEVE IN THE FUTURE OF THE
CAL POLICY AND FEEL THAT THE
STATE FAIRGROUNDS DA IS THE ONLY
ENTITY THAT CAN BE RELIED UPON
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC GOOD.
THIS MUCH LOVE FACILITY BRINGS
TO THE COMMUNITY.
SB TWO EIGHTY ONE AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN IS ACTUALLY TWO DISTINCT
ISSUES IF AMENDED TO ADDRESS
ONLY THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
REPEATED CALLS FOR BANNING GUN
SHOWS WE WOULD BE IN SUPPORT.
HOWEVER AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN WE
SEE THIS BILL AS A PERMANENT
SOLUTION TO A TEMPORARY PROBLEM.
THIS IS THE A A BOARD SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY WITH NEW
APPOINTEES UNDER A NEW GOVERNOR
TO WORK WITH LOCAL COMMUNITY.
COMPLETE THEIR ONGOING
RENOVTIONS WHICH ARE HAPPENING
THEY ARE SPENDING THE MONEY THEY
ARE JUST HAVING TO DEAL WITH IT
ACCORDING TO THE STATE
REGULATIONS TO BE ABLE TO GET
CONTRACTORS BIDS. TO WORK WITH
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY WHICH THEY
ARE DOING WE ALL VOTE WITH OUR
FEET WE SHOW UP WE ARE THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON LOCAL CITY COUNCILS.
BUT THE THOUSANDS THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT COME
TO THE DICKENS CHRISTMAS FAIR
AND THE RODEO AND ALL THE OTHERS.
THEY ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
THE CAPITALIST BECOME AN RIP
REAL QUICK SIR AND I DO
APOLOGIZE SO I UNDERSTAND YOUR
POSITION SUPPORT IF AMENDED WE
WERE JUST ASKING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT.
YEAH I'M GONNA HAVE YOU WRAP UP
IN THE NEXT THIRTY SECONDS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE VERY
CAUTIOUS ABOUT PROVIDING EACH
SIGN EACH SIDE WITH EQUAL TIMES
AND ASK YOU TO WRAP UP IN THE
NEXT THIRTY PLACER.
VERY GOOD -- AS AN EVENT
PROFESSIONAL MYSELF I CAN SPEAK
TO THE FACT THE KALPOE US IS
UNIQUE AND IRREPLACEABLE.
THE OTHER MAJOR VENUES AROUND
THE OTHER BAY AREA OR OTHER
OVERBOOKED OVER PRICED OR POORLY
LAID OUT THE COW PALACE HAS
MULTI PURPOSE SPACES UNDER
CONTINUOUS ROOFS.
OTHER FACILITIES DO NOT HAVE WE
HAVE RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF
LETTERS FROM YOUNG AND OLD
BEGGING US TO SAVE THE COW
PALACE.
TELL US WHERE THEY LEARNED HOW
TO RIDE THEY TELL US THE
IMPORTANCE O HISTORY TODAY THIS
IS NOT NOSTALGIA IT IS PRESENT
DAY INSPIRATION AND EDUCATION
AND WE FEEL THAT THE CURRENT
BOARD IS CAPABLE WE ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THEM. TO RENEW THE
CURRENT BOARD AND T ALLOW THEM
TO DO THEIR JOB THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL BE IN SUPPORT IF
AMENDED AND THERE ARE OTHER
PEOPLE BEHIND ME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DO APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME SIR RENDON I APOLOGIZE --
FOR THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT I
TOOK I AM ACTUALLY ATTEMPTING --
TO SUM UP EVERYBODY'S OPINIONS
BEHIND ME SHAY THANK YOU SIR.
HERE'S IT WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
DO WE LIKE TO BE TO BRING UP --
FIRST BEFORE WE BRING UP THOSE
WHO OPPOSE HIS OR ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HEARING SEEN NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
PART OF IT NO THIS IS SIMPLY IN
ALL RIGHT.
HERE'S A WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
DO WITH THAT WE ARE BRINGING UP
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE HAVE THREE SEATS FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE FRONT FOR
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED.
WHAT WE DIDN'T LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO DO?
IS OPEN IT UP. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SAYS -- SPEAK EITHER WHO ARE
OPPOSED FOR SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
WHAT WE TYPICALLY DO JUST FY I
NOT AT ALL TRYING -- TO LECTURE
AT ALL SO PLEASE DON'T TAKE IT
LIKE THAT IS THAT WE TYPICALLY
HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS. TO
SECONDARY WITNESSES IN
INDIVIDUALS COME UP GIVE THEIR
FIRST AND LAST NAME AND THEIR
STANCE ON THE BILL.
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT LOCAL ISSUE SO WE'RE
GONNA GIVE SOME LEEWAY -- FOR
SPEAKERS TO BE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS -- AS WE TURN IT OVER
AFTER WE HAVE OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES -- WE WELCOME AND BOTH --
FORMER SENATOR FOR AND RETIRED
JUDGE -- COP.
HERE TODAY IS WELL AS A MISTER
BROWN IS WELL CENTER CUT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE
UNLIMITED TIME MISTER BROWN YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- I
THINK YOU'VE RECEIVED ABOUT
MAYBE OF THIRD OF THE STORY.
OF A BILL.
WHICH STANDS AS AN EXAMPLE OF
NON GERMANE US.
BILL AS TO BARGE ONE IS THE GUN
SHOW.
AND THAT'S NOT NEW TO THE
LEGISLATURE -- THAT PART JOE WAS
THE SUBJECT OF LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR WHICH WAS VETOED BY THE
THEN GOVERNOR.
WHO I THINK POINTED OUT?
THE GUN SHOW PRODUCES ABOUT
400-250-01000 DOLLARS IN PROFIT.
TO THE COW PALACE THE COMPOUND
WAS IS. ONE FIFTY FOUR GREG
CULTURAL DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU HEARD REFERENCE TO THE FACT
THAT ARE TO OPEN IN NINETEEN
FORTY ONE IT'S HISTORY DATES
FROM.
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX IT WAS PART
OF THE WORKS PROGRESS
ADMINISTRATION UNDER PRESIDENT
FRANKLIN D..
ROOSEVELT. FIFTY FOUR
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS PLUS.
AT TWENTY FIVE TO FORTY FIVE
FAIRS AND EXPOSITIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M GOING TO CONCENTRATE ON THE
LAND GRAB PORTION OF THIS BILL.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS UNPRECEDENTED
IN THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA LET
ALONE HISTORY OF THE CAL BALANCE.
TRANSFERRING A PARCEL HAVE ABOUT
SEVENTY ACRES. TO A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY WITHOUT ANY
COMPENSATION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE LAND GRAB IN ORDER. TO FULL
FAILS SOMEONE'S.
PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS ABOUT THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH I KNOW I
THINK BETTER THAN ANYBODY IN
THIS AUDIENCE HERE TODAY
INCLUDING MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
IF THIS NEIGHBORHOOD IS BANNED
NEGLECTED WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY
IS THAT.
IT'S A IN THE CITY OF DALY SAID
IT.
BUT I HAVE TO IS RESPONSIBLE.
THIS WAS A DEAD ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO WHEN REDEVELOPMENT WAS A
PART.
OF CALIFORNIA'S LAW AND POLICY
AND FORTUNE A LADY WHETHER AN
OFFER NET NAMED LEE WHEN YE.
IT WAS REJECTED THE AND THE
STATE'S SLANDER DAY OF SELF.
AND IT YEAH IN SO FAR AS
COMMUNITY RELATIONS ARE
CONCERNED.
HERE ARE THE FACTS FOR YOUR
INFORMATION.
FIRST RESPOND OR TRAINING
TRAINING IN RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCIES.
IS HELD AT THE COW PALACE BY
BOTH THE DALY CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AMBULANCE TRAINING FOR
EMERGENCIES IS HELD THE HARM A
PILE SO CALLED PAULOS GROUNDS
EVERY MONTH.
POLICE TRAINING FOR THE DALY
CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT OF KERR'S
ON THE GROUNDS OF THE COW PALACE.
SHARE PRINT SERVICE BUREAUS
VAUNTED METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY TRAINS
IS BONDS DRIVERS ON THE GROUNDS
OF THE CAL PELOSI SELF.
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF ARTS
THE FOUR YEAR COLLEGE IN SAN
FRANCISCO HOLDS GRADUATION
EXERCISE THE JEFFERSON.
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
DONE SO -- AS WELL.
THE THE JEWS ALSO FOR PARKING
FOR THE MOSCONI CONVENTION
CENTER -- VANCE AS REQUIRE.
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
USES IT FOR TRAINING ITS
OFFICERS WHO ARE STATIONED IN
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
I AM THE COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO.
JUST YESTERDAY I AM INFORMED.
THAT THE TRIAL BALANCE HAS BEEN
REQUESTED TO PROVIDE DAYS OF USE.
FOR THE TRAINING OF SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT
CADETS [inaudible]
IS THAT.
DISREGARD OF THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES DALY CITY.
AND SAN FRANCISCO IN THE COUNTY
OF US SAN MATTEO.
IF THIS OCCURS. FIFTY THREE
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CAN BE IN FEAR.
OF A BILL NEXT YEAR THE YEAR
AFTER THE YEAR AFTER THAT. TO
ABOLISH THOSE BURKE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS WHICH ARE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT PART.
NOT JUST OF THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA BUT OF TODAY'S
CALIFORNIA.
A COMMA MAY.
WHAT I SUGGESTED AREAS THAT WAS
IMPLICIT IN THE REMARKS OF
MISTER -- PATTERSON WHOSE FAMILY
FOUNDED THE DICKENS OF FAIR.
DIVIDE THIS BILL IF YOU WILL.
DEAL WITH THE GUN SHOW WHERE
SHOW WHICH HAS BEEN DEALT WITH
Và OUT AT DEL MAR ANOTHER
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT.
WITH THAT IT IS NOW THE SUBJECT
OF VIOLATING GEISHA.
BUT DO NOT PASS THAT PART OF
THERE'S NON GERMANE BILL.
WHICH ENDS THE GLORIOUS HISTORY
AND THE GLORIA GLORIA'S CURRENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
TO ENJOY ADULT FIRST
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT.
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT ONE NAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CENTER WE'RE GRATEFUL TO BROWN
THE FOR GEORGIA FIVE MINUTES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY LOUIS BROWN
ON BEHALF THE WESTERN FAIRS
ASSOCIATION.
SENATOR COP DID A FANTASTIC JOB
I THINK OF IDENTIFYING AND
INFORMING YOU OF THE UTILIZATION
OF THE CAL POLICIES
UNFORTUNATELY WE HEAR THIS ABOUT
DISTRICT AGOSTO STATIONS AND
FAIR GROUNDS.
PRETTY MUCH THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN THAT.
PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S ACREAGE THERE AND IT'S
NOT BEING UTILIZED EVERY DAY OF
THE YEAR THAT THERE'S SOME
EFFORT OVER THERE SOME LACK OF
UTILIZATION HAPPENING HAPPENING.
I CAN TELL YOU WITH WITHOUT A
DOUBT THAT THE COMMUNITIES
AROUND THOSE DISTRIBUTORS SO SEE
ASIANS NO THE BENEFIT THAT THEY
PROVIDE.
AND THAT PROPERTY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN
EMERGENCIES ARISE HOW ARE THE
FIRST PLACE AT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES LOOKS FOR SO --
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
THE SIXTY EIGHT ACRES ACCOUNT
PALACES IS VALUABLE PIECE OF
PROPERTY.
THIS IS CLAIMED TO BE A DISTRICT
BILL BUT IT HAS STATEWIDE
IMPLICATIONS -- JUST A COUPLE
YEARS AGO AB FOURTEEN NINETY
NINE WAS PASSED -- AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM GRAY SIGNED
BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND WHAT WE'LL SEE IN THE MAY
REVISE OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET IS
THE FIRST FORMULA. FOR AB
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE WHICH FOR
THE FIRST TIME IT'S GOING TO
ALLOW THE FAIR GROUNDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BENEFIT
FROM THE SALES TAX REVENUE THAT
THEY GENERATE.
UNLIKE ANY OTHER AGENCIES THEY
GENERATE SALES TAX ON A ANNUAL
BASIS SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS TO
SALES TAX AND THEY GET NO
BENEFIT FROM.
MOST DISTRICT ACCESS OR A NUMBER
OF DISTRICT ASSOCIATIONS GET NO
DIRECT BENEFIT FROM THE STATE AT
ALL THE CALIFORNICA SURVIVE ON
THE REVENUES THEY GENERATE.
IF WE TAKE THIS TRANSFER OF
PROPERTY AND SIMPLY MOVE IT AWAY
THEN EVERY DISTRICT AGOSTO
SITUATION EVERY COUNTY FAIR IN
THE STATE IS GONNA HAVE SOME
NEGATIVE IMPACT BECAUSE THE
SALES TAX REVENUE LOST.
FROM THE COW PALACE THE FUTURE
SALES TAX REVENUE FROM GENERATED
BY THIS NEW AUTHORITY WILL NOT
BE ALLOCATED THROUGH AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE THERE'S NO
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT ALLOWS
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN SO EVERY
DISTRICT AGOSTO SITUATION EVERY
COUNTY FAIR IN THE STATE OF OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED.
BY THIS TRANSFER OF PROPERTY.
I THINK IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
AND IF YOU JUST.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THE CALCULUS
IS SUCCESSFUL FROM A FISCAL
BASIS IT'S GENERATING REVENUE
EVERY YEAR.
IT'S PUTTING MONEY BACK IN THE
FACILITY IS IT ABLE TO ACTUALLY
PUT ALL THE MONEY THAT'S
NECESSARY BACK INTO THE FACILITY
TO MAKE IT [inaudible]
MODERN.
NOT NOT AT ONE CHUNK NOT IN
THERE'S NOT ONE DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION IN THE STATE THE
TABLE TO DO THAT BUT THEY'RE ALL
STARTING TO WORK IN THAT EFFORT
WERE SEEN IN THE GOVERNOR PUT
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE MONIES
FOR DISTRICT AGOSTO SITUATIONS.
THERE RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR THE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE HAPPENING SO.
THIS ELEMENT OF THE BILL WHICH
ISN'T NEW TO THE BILL THIS
TRANSFER PROPERTY.
IS EXTREMELY TROUBLING ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS THE LAST THING
I'D LIKE TO SAY MISTER CHAIR.
IS THAT.
I THINK THAT IT'S OF IT WAS
MISSTATED EARLIER THAT THERE WAS
BEEN LIP SERVICE PAID TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO DEVELOP
THE PROPERTY IN CALCULUS.
THERE'S TWELVE POINT FIVE ACRES
AT THE COW PALACE HAS RIGHT NOW
THAT IS CONSIDERED THE UPPER
PARKING LOT IT IS AN ADJACENT TO
TWELVE POINT FIVE ACRES OF
PRIVATELY OWNED PROPERTY WHICH
IS THEN ADJACENT TO PROPERTY
OWNED BY DALY CITY. SEVEN TO TEN
YEARS AGO.
THERE WERE THEY WERE ALMOST TO
THE POINT OF HAVING AGREEMENT TO
DEVELOP THAT ENTIRE PART OF THE
PROPERTY.
THAT WOULD HAVE INCREASED THAT
WOULD HAVE GENERATED REVENUE FOR
THE CAPITALISTS AND THEN THE
RECESSION HIT.
AND THE DEVELOPERS WALKED AWAY.
THERE'S NOW NEW MANAGEMENT AT
THE CITY OF DALY CITY THERE'S
NOW RENEWED INTEREST BY THE
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNER AND THE
COW PALACE IS ENGAGING IN
CONVERSATIONS. TO DEVELOP.
OR POTENTIALLY DEVELOP THAT
PROPERTY BUT IT WILL TAKE TIME
IT'S A STATE AGENCY THEY HAVE TO
WORK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES.
BUT THERE IS A GENUINE INTEREST
THERE HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST AND
THERE WILL BE IN THE FUTURE. TO
TRY TO PROVIDE SOME BENEFIT BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY FOR THAT
ACREAGE.
THAT IS EASILY DEVELOPED BECAUSE
OF THE WAY IT SITS WITH OTHER
PROPERTIES SO WE THINK THAT THIS
IS GOING TO RESOLVE ITSELF.
THE GOVERNOR LIKE WAS STATED
EARLIER HAS THE ABILITY TO
APPOINT TO THESE MEMBERS AND OF
THE GOVERNOR SO CHOOSES CAN
REMOVE MEMBERS OF A DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION AND APPOINT NEW ONES.
THIS STATE AGENCY IS DOING WHAT
IT'S BEEN TASKED TO DO.
IT HAS STATEWIDE IMPLICATIONS ON
THIS BILL WE ASK FOR A NO VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MISTER
BROWN WE'RE GONNA OPEN IT UP TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO COMMENT.
SO.
WE WILL WELCOME INDIVIDUALS TO
BE TO PLEASE COME FORWARD IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME THE REASON WHY
YOU'RE HERE.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT MANY OF
YOU'VE TRAVELED FROM FAR AND
WIDE WE'RE GONNA GIVE EACH
INDIVIDUAL IF YOU NEED IT.
I A SMALL AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE A
TO SAY YOUR PIECE AND THEN WE'D
LIKE TO BE TO TURN IT OVER TO
CENTER WE ARE TO BE A TO RESPOND.
SO WE NOW WE'RE GONNA WELCOME
FOLKS WHO ARE EITHER OPPOSED OR
SUPPORT IF AMENDED. TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD THE MICROPHONE.
WE WELCOME YOU.
WELCOME SIR GOOD MORNING.
OF MY NAME IS INJURE PATTERSON
I'M WITH THE SAVE THE COW PALACE
COALITION -- THANK YOU EVERYBODY
WHO WHO WROTE THIS BILL AND TO
THOSE WHO SPOKE OPPOSED -- WE
WOULD LIKE -- TO SUPPORT IF
AMENDED WE THINK THIS IS TWO
SEPARATE ISSUES AND THAT IT IS A
LAND GRAB -- AS SENATOR COP SAID
THANK YOU -- AND THAT IF
POSSIBLE TO REMOVE THE JPA
LANGUAGE FROM THIS BILL WITH AN
AMENDMENT AND LET THE THE GUN
SHOWS GO BY THE WAYSIDE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE IN A
VERY -- HERE TODAY THANK YOU.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE OUR
NEXT SPEAKER TO BE A PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
MORNING MY NAME IS CHRIS THERE
THEY CAN THEN WITH THE HELP
HEALTH COALITION.
I AM.
I SUPPORT IF AMENDED FOR THE
MEASURE -- THE CAP HOUSES THE
ONLY VENUE THAT COULD BE USED
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THE COW
PALACE I THE YOU HAVE.
A RICH PEOPLE LIKE FAILS FOR SIR
YOU HAVE NO PLACE NOBODY ELSE
HAS PLACE TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORDS CERTAIN.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KAT
TAYLOR I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND FROM THE COALITION TO SAVE
THAT HELPS OUT HI.
CAL PALACE -- THERE ARE VERY FEW
VENUES IN THE BAY AREA THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO SUPPORT SMALL
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
LIKE THE DICKENS CHRISTMAS FAIR
LIKE VERY AT VARIOUS OTHER
THINGS INTO IT INCLUDING THE
CHEERLEADING COMPETITIONS AND
ALL THE THINGS THAT GO ON THERE.
SO.
WE WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE THAT THE
TWO PIECES OF THE OF THE BILL BE
SEPARATED AND WOULD SUPPORT IT
IF AMENDED.
THANK YOU MISTER [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
HI I'M BETTY SIMMONS I AM FROM
VALLEJO -- I AM.
I SUPPORT THIS PROPOSITION.
WITH THE AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU HE'S MUCH ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU FOR COMING GOOD
MORNING SIR MORNING -- JEFFREY
WEISSMAN OF LOS ANGELES AND
SONOMA COUNTIES.
I'M AN EDUCATOR HISTORIAN AND
ENTERTAINER AND I SUPPORT THIS --
PROPOSITION IF AMENDED THANKS
MUCH SAMMONS GOOD MORNING SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS IT RETURNING --
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
AND I SUPPORT BANNING THE GUN
SHOWS BUT NOT THE OTHER PART OF
THE BILL TO CHANGE THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
HERE TODAY GOOD MORNING MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIMBALL
JACKSON.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE COW PALACE
COALITION.
AND I BELIEVE THE COW PALACE IS
REALLY ESSENTIAL TO OUR
COMMUNITY -- THE ACTIVITIES THAT
GO ON THERE.
ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
AND REFLECTS OUR VALUES AND HOPE
WE CAN SEE YOUR WAY CLEAR.
THANK YOU MS JACKSON.
GOOD MORNING.
I'M ROBERT YOUNG I AM A SAN
FRANCISCO NATIVE FO NOW LIVING
IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M WITH THE SAVE THE COW PALACE
COALITION AND I DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT WITH THE
FOR MENTION TO DIVISION WITH THE
AMENDMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS YOUNG.
GOOD MORNING MORNING LESLIE
PATTERSON I'M FROM NEVADO
CALIFORNIA.
I AM THE PRODUCER OF THE GREAT
DICKENS CHRISTMAS FAIR ALONG
WITH MY FAMILY I REPRESENT OF
THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS AND SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND CUSTOMERS.
WHO COME YEARLY AS A FAMILY
TRADITION TO SEE THAT EVENT?
IT IS A UNIQUE EVENT TO AND THAT
IS THE PLACE FOR US I WOULD
SUPPORT THE BILL IF IT WAS
AMENDED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WAS PATTERSON
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICK ALL AND
FROM THE LABEL.
I AM ONE OF THOSE -- ONE
THOUSAND MENTIONED VOLUNTEERS.
I AS THE BILL IS PRESENTLY.
STATED I WOULD VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE
IT.
IF AMENDED I WOULD ENDORSE IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE SULLIVAN I
WAS BORN IN SAN FRANCISCO HI I
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES FROM THE COW PALACE.
SO I'M A MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY.
THAT ATTENDS EVENTS THERE MY
FRIENDS DO TOO WE DO BECAUSE WE
CAN AFFORD TO ATTEND THE EVENTS
THAT ARE HAPPENING THERE WE
CAN'T GO UP BEFORE.
TO GO ACROSS THE BAY TO OTHER
VENUES.
I HAVE TWO ADULT CHILDREN WHO
WHEN THEY WERE YOUNGER -- WERE
VOLUNTEERS AND THEY STILL ARE --
TEST PARTICIPANTS WITH THE
DICKENS FAIR AND THERE THE FINE
ADULTS THAT THEY ARE TODAY
BECAUSE OF THE SKILLS THAT THEY
LEARN INTERACTING WITH A
COMMUNITY THE PUTS ON THE FAIR
EVERY YEAR.
AND I AM US I WOULD SUPPORT IF
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD MORNING SIR.
MY NAME IS A CRAB I AM FROM
SUNNYVALE CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN WORKING THE DICKENS
FOR HER SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE
IT IS A SOURCE OF INCOME FOR ME.
MANY YEARS OVER AND SENATE
WITHOUT IT I COULDN'T BE THE
PERSON WHO I AM TODAY.
I VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT IF AMENDED.
GRATEFUL THANK YOU FOR COMING
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
WHEN HE WAS LONGER LISTED DAVIS
THE COW PALACE IS BEEN A MAJOR
PART OF MY LIFE?
YOU KNOW BAILING CIRCUS ALL THAT
JAZZ.
I HAVE FAMILY THAT SERVE THE
HERS CITIES AS POLICE OFFICERS
AND I TO WORK THE TO CONSIDER.
SO I WILL ALSO SUPPORT A
FERMENTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND FOR
YOUR WORDS.
MORNING SIR GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MY NAME IS JOHN CAME I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I LIVE THERE.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL IF IT IS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TEN IN TOAY GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARCO
LARA AM ARISEN OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M WITH THE COALITION TO
SAVE THE COW PALACE SO I HAVE ---PERFORMED AT THE COW PALACE FROM --
FOR AS LONG AS IT'S BEEN THERE
AND WITH THE DICKENS HERE FOR AS
LONG AS NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE I
WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF HIS BILL
IF IT WERE AMENDED.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TUNING.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LOW PAY
GAP JUNIOR I'M A NATIVE SAN
FRANCISCO I WEAR MANY HATS.
I AM A FILM PRODUCER I DIRECT
MOVIES -- AND I'M ALSO A THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE GEORGE
WASHINGTON HIGH SCHOOL NICE
ASSOCIATION.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT I REALLY IN
PASSION ABOUT SAVING THE COW
PALACE BECAUSE IT'S A W. A
PROJECT.
AND ALL MY OTHER PROJECTS I'M
TRYING TO SAY THE MURALS ANDSAN
FRANCISCO.
FROM.
A LOT OF CRAZY PEOPLE TRYING TO
THINK THAT WE SHOULD A RACE
HISTORY NOT DEAL WITH HISTORY.
I I DEFINITELY THINK THAT.
ANY ATTEMPT TO HURT TOUCH WITH.
THE CATAPULSE IS ALL ABOUT IS A
DEFINITE.
NO NO FOR SHORT TERM ANSWERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE.
PROVIDING COMING HERE TODAY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO.
MAY BE OPPOSED TO OR SUPPORT IF
AMENDED WE WELCOME YOU IN YOUR
TESTIMONY TO COULD PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME.
HEARING SEEN NINE WERE IN TURN
IT OVER TO THE SENATOR TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND CENTER WIENER
AND THEN -- WILL OPEN UP AA AS
TO PROCEDURAL QUESTION.
ABS MY LETTER OF MARCH
NINETEENTH IN YOUR FILE.
I RECEIVED A LETTER AND LET'S
GET IT BECAUSE THERE WAS AN IN
THE ANALYSIS OPPOSE.
THE COMMITTEE I DID RECEIVE THE
LETTER MISSING CHESTER CORRECT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CUP I THINK SOME MEMBERS HAVE
IT WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT --
EVERY MEMBER HAS IT SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE -- GOVERNS IN FINANCE
STAFF MAKE THOSE COPIES NOW --
IN BE ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE.
ALL RIGHT -- BUT SOME MEMBERS DO
YOU HAVE THE LETTER IS WELL
WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER TO SENATOR
WINNER SENATOR WIENER. FOR
RESPONSIBLE OPEN UP FOR
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN --
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF PUBLICLY CAME OUT --
TODAY -- I WANNA MAKE ONE THING
CRYSTAL CLEAR -- IN CASE THERE'S
ANY MISUNDERSTANDING BECAUSE
SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS WE'RE
HEARING ABOUT THIS BILL.
I THINK A SEEM TO ASSUME THAT
THE BILL DICTATES BUT THE CAL
PALACE WILL BE TORN DOWN.
THE BILL THERE'S NO SUCH THING.
ALL THE BILL DOES THE ONE THING
IT DOES DICTATE ISN'T UNDER THE
GUN SHOWS -- AND I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT THERE'S SO MUCH
SUPPORT. FOR THAT -- BUT THE
BILL.
TRANSFERS THE LAND SO THAT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY CAN MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE FUTURE.
BACK COULD MEAN BY AINTAINING
THE CALIPARI IT COULD MEAN THAT
OF AND DID OF COURSE WOULD HAVE
TO BE FINANCE BECAUSE THERE IS
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
HAS TO BE DONE ON IT.
BUT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY COULD
DECIDE TO KEEP THE CAL PALACE.
OR NOT THAT WILL BE A LOCAL
DECISION THIS BILL DOES NOT
DICTATE THE REMOVAL OF THE CAL
PALACE PERIOD -- I ALSO JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE I MET WITH --
WHAT'S IMPAIRS ASSOCIATION --
LAST WEEK AND WE COMMITTED THAT
WE'RE ALL GONNA TRY TO WORK
TOGETHER -- ON THIS ISSUE AND
ENGAGE THE GOVERNOR AND OTHERS
SO WE WANT THIS TO BE A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS BUT
REGARDLESS THERE HAS TO BE.
A CHANGE HERE -- YOU KNOW I WILL
ALSO HIS NOTE -- DIET WE
CONTINUE TO HEAR THIS.
ONE WHY NOT ASSEMBLYMAN TING WHO
REPRESENTS OUR CITY AND I'D MET
WITH MARK CAUGHT -- CENTER COP'S
WIFE WHO IS THE CHAIR OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE CAL
PALACE -- IS SHE IT CONTINUE TO
DEFEND THE GUN SHOWS WE SAID
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT DOING
LEGISLATION TO TRANSFER THE LAND
IT WAS THIS CONTINUAL DEFENSE OF
THE GUN SHOWS WE SAW IT AND
CENTER COPS LETTER A DEFENSE OF
THE GUN SHOWS.
SO EVEN AFTER ALL THIS TIME.
THIS AGENCY CONTINUES NOT.
TO EITHER HERE OR UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY IS
SAYING THIS IS NOT A LAND GRAB.
THIS IS NOT ME OR ANYONE IS
GRABBING THE LAND THIS IS ABOUT
THE ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES OF
DALY CITY SAN MATTEO COUNTY AND
SAN FRANCISCO MAKING DECISIONS.
ABOUT THE FUTURE ABOUT LAND
THAT'S NOT A LAND GRAB THIS IS A
PUBLIC PROCESS.
SO THEY CAN BE PUBLIC DECISION
MAKING BY ELECTED OFFICIALS --
ABOUT THE FUTURE -- YOU KNOW
CENTER COP MENTIONED THAT THE
DALY CITY POLICE AND AT A
SEVENTY ANS OF PD ARE USING THE
SITE -- THAT MAY BE THE CASE BUT
AS A REMINDER UNANIMOUS VOTES
FROM THE GOVERNING BODIES OF
EACH O THOSE CITIES SUPPORTING
THIS LEGISLATION -- SO.
YOU KNOW WHATEVER USE IS BEING
MADE YES IF YOU HAVE SIXTY EIGHT
ACRES OF LARGELY ON USE LAND --
YOU CAN MAKE SOME USE OF IT BUT
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE BEST
USE OF OUR LAND AND THAT SHOULD
BE A LOCAL -- DECISION -- SO
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR YES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR NIELSEN IN THE VICE CHAIR.
I HAVE CONCERNS THAT THIS BILL
IN EFFECT IS EMINENT DOMAIN BY
ANOTHER MEETS [inaudible]
NOW.
THE CONCERN ALSO IS THE THREAT
TO THE AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS.
AND AS YOU NEGOTIATE WITH
WESTERN FAIRS CENTERED AT
APPRECIATE IF YOU'D BE VERY
COGNIZANT OF THE CONCERNS OF ALL
OF THE AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS.
AND THAT THERE'S SOME KIND OF
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD BE THE
GOVERNING THAT THIS IS NON
PRECEDENTIAL.
A NON OBLIGATORILY TO ANY OTHER
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT
[inaudible]
ANY CITY.
FRESNO FOR EXAMPLE COULD DECIDE
THERE WAS A LOT OF MORE REVENUE
IN.
DEVELOPING THAT PROPERTY.
OR AFFECTING THEIR LOW INCOME
HOUSING OR HOME AND IS
HOMELESSNESS HOUSING ON THESE
SITES.
AND THEY THEN IF THEY'RE
FRUSTRATED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WOULD COME HERE.
AND THAT'S A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
SO I'D ASK YOU TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT AS WE PROCEED.
THIS IS THESE FARES.
ARE OF INTEGRAL PART OF OUR
HISTORY.
IN OUR WN LOUNGE WE'VE SHOWCASE
THE POSTERS FROM THOSE HISTORIC
FAIRS.
WE MUST NOT FORGET THEM.
WE MUST NOT COMPROMISE SO I AM
ASKING THAT INDEED COMPROMISED
BE AFFECTED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS YES IN
CENTER WHERE HE WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND.
SO -- SENDER ABSOLUTELY YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT -- AS I EXPRESSED
TO MISTER BROWN THAT WHAT WE
WILL BE -- WORKING TOGETHER AND
DIALOGUING TOGETHER -- ABOUT
LEGISLATION WE WERE VERY CLEAR
THIS IS NOT TO BE A PROCESS AND
THIS IS A PRETTY UNIQUE
SITUATION INTO UNIQUE SORRY
UNIQUE SITUATION -- UNIQUE
HISTORY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I IN JUST
A FEW OBSERVATIONS COMMENTS AND
A FEW QUESTIONS BUT TO THE
LETTER FROM SENATOR COP -- WHO
IS VERY SPECIFIC ON IT A
SPECIFIC DATE THAT -- HE HAS
BEEN AT THE COW PALACE SINCE
DECEMBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE DO
YOU REMEMBER WHERE YOU WERE ON
THAT DATE.
SO I TO SAID ABOUT SIT AND THINK
ABOUT THAT I COULDN'T REMEMBER
WHERE I WAS ON THAT DAY.
TOO I'M.
I WAS -- AGITATED BUT THE NEXT
DAY I WAS BORN.
YOU'RE DATING YOURSELF.
BUT I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS KIND
OF FUNNY TO SEE THAT DATE.
IN YOUR LETTER FIRST SENTENCE
BUT I I TO ENJOYED BEATING ON
THE ORANGE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
BACK WHEN SCHWARZENEGGER WHICH
PRESIDENT I WAS ONE OF THE AS A
SUPERVISOR WAS ONE OF THE
BIDDERS SO I CERTAINLY REMEMBER
THAT INTERESTING TIME -- ARE WE
WERE NOT THE WINNING BIDDER BUT
THE WHOLE THING WAS RESCINDED
AFTER A BRIEF TIME AND SO THE
ORANGE COUNTY IS STILL.
BEING RUN -- AS A A DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION AND AND
DOING WELL -- I DID SOME
RESEARCH THE ORANGE COUNTY FAIR
I LIVE CLOSE ENOUGH TO THE
ORANGE COUNTY FAIR THAT I
ACTUALLY WALKED THERE.
YOU KNOW I MEAN IT'S A FEW
BLOCKS WHEN I WHEN THE BEARS ON
ANY WILL BOTHER WITH THE PARK I
JUST MY WIFE IS WHAT.
BUT HAVING.
IT HAS THE CROSSROADS OF THE
WEST GUN SHOW EVERY OTHER MONTH
AND AND I SEE NO INCREASE AND
THE ISSUES THAT ARE BEING RAISED.
FOR THE COW PALACE SAID THAT
THAT ISN'T.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHETHER I I JUST
CAN'T GET A COROLLARY SO I'M I'M
I'M SAYING I I DON'T SEE.
OF THE SAME ISSUES THAT ARE
BEING RAISED ABOUT THE GUN SHOW --
SO SO WITH THAT I JUST HAD.
YOU KNOW DOING SOME MORE
RESEARCH YOU ARE YOU KNOW IT AND
MEETING WITH IDIVIDUALS THERE
IS A SAN MATTEO COUNTY FAIR AND
THERE IS THE COW PALACE BOTH IN
SAN MATEO COUNTY.
AND THE COW PALACE IS A DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL.
ASSOCIATION IT'S PART OF THE
FAIRS LIKE ORANGE COUNTY IS BUT
THE SAN MATEO.
COUNTY FAIRS ACTUALLY COUNTY
PROPERTY.
AND IT'S A COUNTY.
YOU KNOW TO SEARCH DIFFERENT
FROM ALL THE AG GROUPS SO I I'M
JUST CURIOUS FROM ANY OF THE
PARTIES -- HAS EVER BEEN
DISCUSSION INSTEAD OF DOING YOUR
PROPOSAL OF DOING A SWAP.
THE V. CALIPARI ODDLY COULD THAT
THE DOES THE AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICT IS BOTH SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY AND CEMETERY COUNTY AND A
SMALL PIECE.
OF THE CAL PALACE AXES IN SAN
FRANCISCO -- THE BULK OF IT IS
AND CEMETERY COUNTY IN DALY CITY
BUT THOSE CROSSOVER IN SAN
FRANCISCO SO IT IS A TO COUNTY --
I'M UNAWARE IF THERE'S EVER BEEN
A PROPOSAL -- TO DO A SWAP -- SO
I CAN'T COMMENT ON THAT LET ME
GIVE YOU AN ANSWER -- AS FAR AS
I KNOW AND I'LL DATE THIS FROM.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE WHEN I WAS
ELECTED TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THERE HAS
NOT BEEN ANY DISCUSSION OVER
MERGING.
OKAY JUST KIND OF CURIOUS AS I'M
LOOKING AT THE MAP YOU KNOW
BEING FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BEEN.
ALL OVER YOUR COUNTIES BUT THE
FEELING OF MA I I KNOW YOU THE
TREASURES HERE OF CHARGE OF
MANAGING THE CASH.
CONTROL IS PROBABLY THE RIGHT
PERSON ASKED ME BUT YOU MAY KNOW.
IT IS OUR OUR OUR THE FDA'S EVEN
IN THAT CHART OF ACCOUNTS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THEY
ARE A LISTED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AG.
SO KAREN ROSS -- DOES NO WE HAVE
I THINK SEVENTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
FAIRGROUNDS AROUND THE STATE AND
SO -- IT IS UNDER HER DEPARTMENT
BUT YES THERE THEY GET NO CASH
NO SUPPORT.
FROM THE STATE RIGHT AND AT THAT
WOULD EVEN BE IN THE CHART OF
ACCOUNTS I MEAN IF THEY WERE IF
YOU WANTED TO DO SOMETHING FOR
THESE AFFAIRS REJECT.
IT'S STILL IN THE CHART OF
ACCOUNTS -- BUT BECAUSE OF THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT FINANCIAL
CRISIS -- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
USED TO BUDGET A CERTAIN AMOUNT
LOUIS PROBABLY CAN TELL YOU HOW
MUCH WAS BUDGETED.
A WE FOUGHT FOR IT TO GET SOME
MONEY BACK INTO THE BUDGET --
WHICH WE WAS JUST UP -- A
PORTION OF THE SOME THAT USED TO
BE PROVIDED TO THE FAIRS AND
THEN IT WAS NEVER RESTORED.
AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK A LOT
OF THE COMPOUNDING PROBLEMS HAVE
OCCURRED BECAUSE THE MONEY WAS
NEVER -- RESTORED BACK IN THE
BUDGET AND THEN YOU KNOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY THE PROPOSED
THE BILL TO ALLOCATE THE SALES
TAX TO HELP THE FAIRS BECAUSE OF
THE BUDGET ISSUES BUT I THINK --
LOUIS PROBABLY I CAN TELL YOU
WHERE.
ON HOW MUCH MONEY IN AND WHERE
ALL THESE ACCOUNTS ARE BURIED.
THANK YOU MANAGER MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF THE WESTERN
FAIRS ASSOCIATION I IN FACT A
HORSE RACING WAS LEGALIZED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE AS BECAUSE
IT WAS DESIGNED TO BE A SUPPORT
FOR THE NETWORK A CALIFORNIA
FAIRS.
AND SO ALL THE WAY UP UNTIL --
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER'S TERM --
THERE WAS A PERCENTAGE OF
LICENSE FEES A GENERATED BY
HORSE RACING THAT WENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AGRICULTURE.
AND THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS I NEVER
REALLY REACHED THAT AND SO
REALLY AT THE HEYDAY I THINK WE
WERE RECEIVING ABOUT THIRTY TWO
MILLION ON AN ANNUAL BASIS THAT
WOULD THEN GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
THEY WOULD THEN DISTRIBUTE THAT
AMONGST THE FAIRS DISTRICT
AGOSTO SOLUTIONS AND COUNTY
FAIRS -- TO COVER OPERATING
EXPENSES BUT THEN THEY ALSO
COVERED OTHER -- AREAS LIKE
INSURANCE COSTS WORKERS
COMPENSATION RETIREMENT EXCEPT --
FOR THEN.
THE RECESSION HIT.
A GOVERNOR BROWN A RESCINDED ALL
THIRTY TWO MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND FOR A PERIOD OF
ABOUT THREE YEARS -- AND FAIRS
WERE LEFT TO SURVIVE ON JUST
WHAT THE GENERATED A GOVERNOR
BROWN ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO --
THEN.
ADDED THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
HELPING THE SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZE
FAIRS.
SO THERE'S DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATIONS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE BASED ON THE REVENUE
THE FARE.
ON THE SMALLEST FAIRS CLASSES
ONE THROUGH -- FOUR ARE THE ONES
THAT NOW RECEIVE SOME NOMINAL
SUPPORT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO HELP
THEM SUSTAIN ON THEIR OPERATING
SIDE -- BUT NO FAIR GROUND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY --
UNLESS THERE'S A SPECIAL
ALLOCATION RECEIVES ANY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ASSISTANCE.
OR ANYTHING BEYOND THAT NOMINAL
AMOUNT.
AND YOU'RE NOT GIVING ANYTHING
TO THE STATE EITHER.
WELL I WOULD -- AIM FOR PENSION
COSTS TO CALPERS SIR YES THE
SALES TAX CELLS CELLS TAX
GENERATED -- AT A LOCAL LEVEL
THE HOTELS THAT ARE GENERATED
THE RESTAURANT.
THAT'S JUST CORRECT CORRECT YES
FOR THE ON THE ON THE GROUNDS
THAT FAIRS DO PAY -- YOU KNOW
THEY PAY -- FOR AUTO INSURANCE
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
INSPECTOR SERVICES THEY PAY
THEIR INSURANCE COSTS THEY PRO
RATTA FEES HOW TO THE DEPARTMENT
SO THERE IS SOME MONEY.
THAT COMES BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
SO -- THESE.
FAIR GROUNDS ARE ON THE RUN.
FINANCIALLY WHATEVER THEY
GENERATE THEY KEEP -- I KNOW
THAT LAST YEAR SENATOR NIELSEN
AYE IN THE BUDGET CONFERENCE
OMMITTEE WE APPROVED A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR.
AMOUNT FOR THE CALYX BOTH YOU
KNOW BECAUSE IT AS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN AS HAS INCREASING
COSTS TO AND I HEAR ON THE RADIO
THIS MORNING THAT THEY GET A
HOMELESS SHELTER FOR HUNDRED
BEDS -- TO SO THINGS ARE YOU
KNOW HAPPENING TO THESE THESE
THESE FACILITIES.
SO I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS --
SENATOR -- IF IF THE BIG ISSUE
FIRST WAS THE GUN SHOW WHITE ONE
IS IN THE STATE JUST.
THEY WOULD BE EARNING ON THE GUN
SHOW AND AND WILL GIVE THAT TO
YOU AND SWAP IT OUT.
SO THAT THE THE PAIR GROUND IS
IS IS.
IS EVEN AND THEN YOU TAKE CARE
OF THAT ISSUE IF IT'S AN ISSUE
AND THEN.
AND THEN THEN WE LOOK AT MAYBE A
BIGGER PLAN SAYING WHAT WE DO TO
THESE FAIRGROUNDS TO HELP THEM
OUT WITH THIS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
SURE SO -- FIRST OF ALL THE THE
WITH REGARD VARYING ESTIMATES
FROM THE CAL PALACE FOR THE GUN
SHOW GENERATED ABOUT A
1-001-005-0000 DOLLARS A YEAR IN
REVENUE OUT OF A FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR -- BUDGET THAT THEY HAVE
SO IT'S A SMALL PORTION --
BECOME PALACES AND TOLD US
BECAUSE THEY BONTA ME INTO
SOMEONE AND TING ASKING FOR I
THINK TEN OR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO FIX THE ROOF AND DO
OTHER THINGS THIS IS IT'S A TINY
DROP IN THE BUCKET BUT TO BE
CLEAR.
EVEN THOUGH THE GUN SHOW ISSUE
HAS DOMINATED THE THE NEWS AND
TERMS OF THE TONE DEAFNESS OF
THE CALIPARI LOCAL COMMUNITY
ONCE THAT'S BEEN THE HEADLINES.
THE ISSUE RUNS MUCH DEEPER THAN
THAT AND THE LAND USE ISSUES ARE
ALSO -- A DEEP FRUSTRATION -- IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY SO THESE ARE
BOTH SIGNIFICANT ISSUES EVEN
THOUGH ONE IS GOT MORE PUBLIC
ATTENTION.
I GUESS WE COULD SOLVE THIS BY
JUST BUDGETING TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
RIGHT THE AND THAT WOULD BE A
FOR THE GUN SHOW JUST THAT THAT
COMPONENT AND THE OTHER PART OF
IT SENATORS IT'S MORE OF A
FAMILY FIGHT RIGHT IT'S LIKE WE
WE DON'T LIKE THE WAY THIS PLACE
IS.
BEING MANAGED AND SO THEREFORE
WE'RE GOING.
TO HAVE TO PUT A NEW OWNERSHIP
SO TO SPEAK AND AND I DON'T KNOW
OUR EVERY YOU KNOW THAT THE TERM.
THE TERMS OF IN USE LAND GRAB --
EMIT EMINENT DOMAIN -- I'M REAL
NERVOUS I'M ARM REAL NERVOUS
ABOUT THAT KIND OF APPROACH
BECAUSE OF WHAT IT WHAT IT SAYS
TO EVERYBODY ELSE AND AND IT'S
LIKE WE'RE TRYING TO SETTLE.
A LOCAL PROBLEM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I I HAVE TROUBLE
WITH THAT TO HELP ME OUT WELL.
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT.
THIS IS NOT LIKE TO CITIES
FIGHTING WITH EACH OTHER GO TO
SACRAMENTO THIS IS.
LAND THAT IS THE PROBLEM IS IT
AGENCY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH A BOARD OF
DIRECTORS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOT LIKE LOCAL FIGHT
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY HAS WITH A STATE
AGENCY THAT IS NOT LISTENING THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY AT OUR ONLY
RECOURSE OUR ONLY RECOURSE.
IS TO GO TO THE STATE FIX THE
SITUATION SO THAT'S WHY IT'S
HERE.
BUT YOU'RE ASKING THE STATE TO
IN A SENSE TRANSFER OVER IT'S
THE A A TO A J. P. A. N. THAT.
THAT'S KIND OF INTERESTING ASK
ISN'T RIGHT AND WE AND WE DO
HAVE IN TIME I WAS IN THE BILL
THE WORKED OUT WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
ABOUT WORKING ON HOW THE
FINANCIAL -- ARRANGEMENT WILL
OCCUR -- AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE STATE -- IS IS
MADE WHOLE AND THAT COULD HAPPEN
IN THE FUTURE IF THERE'S
DEVELOPMENT HERE -- THE STATE
COULD HAVE A STAKE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT THERE COULD BE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS OF
DOING IT BUT WE DID WE HAVE
AGREED TO THAT TIME LANGUAGE.
AND THAT WILL BE AN ISSUE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL.
I'M JUST WONDERING CENTER COP
YOU HAVE A REBUTTAL TO THAT.
HELLO DECIDED YOU YO REVIEW OF
HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT.
HASN'T FOR ALMOST A DECADE
GOTTEN ANY MONEY OUT OF A STATE
BUDGET.
AND NUMBER -- TWO IT MAKES MONEY
IT TURNS A PROFIT EVERY YEAR.
AND CONTRA RATED TESTIMONY FROM
AS MAMA IT IS IN GOOD SHAPE
EXCEPT FOR THE ROOF [inaudible]
AND INCLUDING MONEY. FOR A NEW
ROOF WOULD BE AN ACT THAT WOULD
DISTINGUISH THOSE COMMITTEE NOT
JUST IN MY MIND BUT IN THE MINDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
REPRESENTED.
BY THOSE WHO TESTIFIED AS
WITNESSES. TO SUPPORT A BILL
THAT EXCLUDED BUT TRANSFER.
WITHOUT COMPENSATION OF THE
SIXTY EIGHT OR SEVENTY ACRES
ITSELF.
THANK YOU SANDERS THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE
NEED TO SHOW QUESTIONS ARE
COMMON SIDE IF YOU COMMENTED
LIKE THEIR TO MAKE BUT BEFORE WE
DO LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE IN THE FINAL
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY ON ON ALL SIDES.
WE ARE ALWAYS GRATEFUL THAT
CENTER COPPICING COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SIR AND WIENER THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THE AMENDMENTS.
BECAUSE THE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
THERE SOME FAMILIAR THEMES --
AND SIMILAR THEMES THAT MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF ADVANCED.
ONE IS THERE'S LANGUAGE THAT --
THE SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S
AGREED -- TO TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE DOES NOT LOSE REVENUE AS A
RESULT OF THE TRANSFER.
I IN THAT THE STATE IS CAPITAL.
IN THAT FOLLOWS PRESIDENT WITH
OTHER LAND WHETHER IT IS A
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS -- TO
STATE HIGHWAY RIGHT AWAY CENTER
AND MAINTAINED TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE GENERAL FUND IS
CAPITAL.
I IN THAT BRINGS IT INTO
CONSISTENT STATUS WITH PREVIOUS
[inaudible]
ANGEL TRANSACTION.
IN ADDITION IN THIS IS AN ITEM
THAT AT SHARED SENATOR AND ALSO
SHARED WITH MISTER BROWN -- IN
NOT HAVING A BILL THAT CREATES
PRECEDENT FOR OTHER FAIRS -- IN
I DO AGREE WITH -- CENTER
NIELSEN FIND ENSURING THAT THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE PRECEDENT
SETTING AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
HI AND THERE IS INTENT LANGUAGE
THAT IS NOW IN THIS BILL HAS
BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR.
I'LL ALSO SAY THAT -- WE ALL
HAVE.
ISSUES WITHIN OUR DISTRICTS THAT
ARE OF UTMOST CONCERN.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
THIS AS A LOCAL ISSUE.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS BEEN AN
ONGOING COMMUNITY DISCUSSION --
WITH -- A DALY CITY -- WITH THE
COUNTY SAN MATTEO -- AND
SOMEWHAT WITH THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
BUT I THINK BOTTOM LINE IS IS
GOING TO BE AN ISSUE THIS
COMMAND TO MORE IMPORTANT NEVER
TO BE ABLE TO RESOLVE.
I'M IN THERE ARE CHALLENGES --
AND I'M NOT FROM THE AREA BUT
NOT VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE AREA
THERE ARE CHALLENGES IN THAT
PART OF THE CITY -- IN WHILE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DONE SHOWS --
THAT IS ONE ISSUE -- AND WE TAKE
A LOOK AT WHETHER IT IS THE
PRIVATE SECTION FOR THE COW
PALACE SECTION.
DALY CITY SECTION.
OF WHAT IT MAKE IT LAND OR
POTENTIAL LAND THERE ARE DEVELOP
AROUND -- THE COW PALACE.
THERE COULD POTENTIALLY BE SOME
HIGHEST AND BEST USE.
AND BEING VERY HONEST ABOUT IT --
THE ONLY WAY TO BE ABLE TO START
HAVING A COLLABORATIVE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE FROM AN OUTSIDER LOOKING IN.
FOLKS ARE DONE AGAIN IS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THIS ISSUE CONTINUE
TO ALLOW FOR THE CONVERSATION.
THAT'S WHY I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS TODAY --
THAT'S WHY WE'VE ADVANCED THE
AMENDMENTS. TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE IS KEPT WHOLE THIS IS NOT
CREATE A PRECEDENT AND IT IS
TIME FOR THIS CONVERSATION THAT --
BE RESOLVED ONCE AND FOR ALL --
IN ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT IS NOT
GONNA MAKE SOME FOLKS HAPPY --
BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE NONE THE
LESS.
SO THAT THAT'S WHERE I CURRENTLY
STAND TODAY NO TURN OVER -- TO
CENTER WIENER -- FOR ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS RESPECTFUL S. FROM MY
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH IN A
WINNER -- PLEASE.
CENTER AND WE DO WE HAVE THAT
PRESIDENTIAL LANGUAGE.
THE LOOK AT THIS AS WE DO IT'S
WITHIN THE PACKET OF WHAT WE PUT
OUT -- REAL QUICK SO WE CAN SHOW
THE CENTER JUST FLAG IT TO ME I
WOULD.
NO IT'S OKAY WE'RE TO PASS RIGHT
OVER IT NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT IS HOLDING UP FOR A MOMENT
IF IT'S IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH
FOLKS US SO THAT FOLKS CAN READ?
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR USING
UNGRATEFUL OF FREE BRING THAT
FORWARD ALL RIGHT.
THERE'S AN CHEN WE'D LIKE TO BE
TO SEE IF THERE IS A MOTION THE
MOTION IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE GOVERNOR -- ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL
AGAIN.
IN WINTER THANK YOU TREASURE Mà
THANK YOU.
CENTER COP THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY AS WELL AS
LANCASTER CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE CHOIR HI MCGUIRE
I'M MORE LOCK.
OR UNLOCK NOBEL [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
RICARDO.
YOUR TOTAL AYE NIELSEN NO THE NO
WINNER HI.
HI.
THERE IS CURRENTLY A FOUR TO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPENED AN ADD ON AS WE HAVE
FOLKS POINTS IN COMMITTEE.
IS A GERMAN WE HAVE ONE FINAL
BILL AND I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO CENTER
NIELSEN -- CENTER NIELSEN HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY PATIENT HERE
TODAY.
EDIT WE NEED A PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SENATOR.
WELL THAT THAT WHAT WE TAKE
THIRTY SECOND BREAK IN LET FOLKS
EXIT THE COMMITTEE WERE TO TAKE
A THIRTY SECOND. TWO SIXTY
SECOND RECESS TO ALLOW FOLKS TO
EXIT THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
FOR WE'RE NOT GONNA BE US BACK
TOGETHER.
I AND I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
BE ABLE TO KNOWLEDGE CENTER
NIELSEN -- CENTER NIELSEN IS A
MEMBER GALLAGHER BEEN THROUGH
HELL AND BACK -- WITH.
THE FIRE IN PARADISE ON THERE
HAVE NOT BEEN ANY BIGGER
CHAMPIONS IN CENTER NIELSEN --
AS WELL AS A SIN NUMBER HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIRELESS WORK SIR YOUR
TIRES WORK ON BEHALF OF YOU
COUNTY -- IN PARADISE -- IT IS
BEING -- IMPRESSIVE TO SEE --
AND HOW YOU DELIVER FOR THE
FOLKS YOU CARE SO MUCH ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO AS THEIR NIELSEN SB --
TWO FORTY NINE WHICH DOES HAVE A
FOCUS ON BUTTE COUNTY CENTER THE
FORESHORES.
AND I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
TO FOR WORKING WITH US YOU
HAVING SUFFERED SIMILARLY IN THE
AREA THAT YOU REPRESENT.
YOU KNOW THE ISSUES AND WE'VE
APPRECIATED WORKING WITH YOU.
WE HAVE HAD THIS CAMPFIRE THIS.
DIDN'T DISTURB DESTROY THE CITY
OF PARADISE.
THAT AFFECTED THE ENTIRE RICH.
SOME HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THAT INHABIT.
THAT LONG RICH FROM CHICO.
UP TO EVEN BEYOND [inaudible]
PARADISE.
A LOT OF LIVES WERE LOST.
THE PROPER THE PURPOSE HERE IS
TO HELP.
THE COMMUNITIES COME BACK.
AND TO COME BACK AS QUICKLY AS
THEY CAN.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE LEGISLATIVE
BODIES IN BUTTE COUNTY TO EXTEND
THE LIFE OF THE SUBDIVISION MAPS.
THAT THEY HAVE TO OPERATE UNDER
FOR UP TO THREE YEARS.
LET ME THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
MUCH BUT FOR FOLKS TRYING TO
TOTALLY GET BACK ON THEIR FEET
AND IN CASE OF THAT CITY IT'S
JUST ALMOST TOTALLY.
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET
[inaudible]
AND THERE WOULD BE CONDITIONS
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE MET.
THAT WOULD BE RELATED TO SINGLE
OR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
AND ONE OF THE GOALS MEMBERS OF
PARADISE IS TO IN FACT.
BE ABLE TO INCORPORATE MORE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
IN THIS PLAN.
THAT THIS PLAN WAS APPROVED ON
OR AFTER JANUARY -- ONE SECTION
NOT LATER THAN MARCHTHIRTY
FIRST.
NINETEEN AND HAS NOT EXPIRED
BEFORE THE EFFECTIVE DATE.
OF THE BILL.
THE EXPIRATION DATE WAS EXTENDED
BY AB THIRTEEN OH THREE AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN EXTEND YOUR
BRUTAL WINDOW TO ANY LEGISLATIVE
BENCH FAVOR STATE AGENCY
APPROVAL FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A PROJECT LOCATED.
WITHIN THAT MAP FOR THOSE THREE
YEARS.
IT'S EASY TO COMPLY WITH.
MAP CONDITIONS IN [inaudible]
GOOD TIMES.
NOT ALWAYS BUT SOMETIMES IT IS
ANYWAY.
BUT IT'S SUCH DEVASTATION OF
THIS.
IT'S VERY MUCH AN IMPEDIMENT.
THAT PARTY IMPEDIMENT ADJUST THE
PAUL THAT HOVERS OVER THE WHOLE
REGION.
AND THE AMBITION OF INDIVIDUALS
TO GO BACK IN.
RE AND OCCUPY THEIR PROPERTY
THEIR HOMES THE BUSINESS
[inaudible]
THIS EXTENSION.
WOULD.
ONLY THE BUTTE COUNTY.
IF I MAY HAVE MISTER CHARLES
THIS OF WHITE.
THESE ARE PLANNING DIVISION OF
BUTTE COUNTY.
AND HE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS WHITE
AND ASK YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF IF YOU DON'T MIND
SIR WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK AS WELL BUT YOU
DO HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE
WELCOME YOU. TO COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
OVER THESE PAST MANY MONTHS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- THIS
IS A PARTIAL SOLUTION TO A
COMPLEX PROBLEM THE A CUTE
HOUSING CRISIS THAT EXISTS IN
BUTTE COUNTY AND ITS CITIES.
OF AS A RESULT OF THE CAMP FIRE
WHICH DESTROYED OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND HOMES AND THESE THE
THIS BILL WOULD AS AS INDICATED
EXPAND THE LIFE OF SUBDIVISION
MAPS IN THE COUNTY FOR UP TO
THIRTY SIX MONTHS UPON APPROVAL
BY THE LEGISLATIVE BODY -- IN
BUTTE COUNTY UNINCORPORATED
BI<c.cyan> COUNTY ALONE THIS THESE</c>
TENTATIVE MAPS REPRESENT ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
NEW RESIDENTIAL UNITS.
THEIR CRITICALLY NEEDED AND WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR SET THAT
SOCIAL WHITE WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE BEFORE WE OPEN IT UP
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT
CENTER YES I SENIOR GONNA BE-ACCEPTING IT THE AMENDMENTS HAS
PRESENTED.
THE MOST AUTHORS IN THEM THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
OPEN IT UP.
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE AT THIS
TIME.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO IN
SUPPORT.
WE NOW WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME THOSE FOR POST.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSED NOT GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
ABOUT ON THE FLOOR THIS IS DO
PASSES AND MANY TO PREPARATIONS
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE.
PLEASE MR BY SHEER.
MR CHERUB AND I LOVE TO READ
CALIFORNIA STREET I'M JUST
RECENTLY RE READING.
BY THE NINETEEN OH SIX
EARTHQUAKE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
HOW QUICKLY.
THAT CITY WAS REBUILDING WITHIN
ALMOST THREE YEARS -- SO I I A
PERM [inaudible]
SENATORS.
EFFORTS HERE.
HAPPY TO SERVE GIVE IT A GIVE IT
A SUPPORT WROTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE.
I GUESS IT WOULD JUST BE THAT WE
HAVE A SPIRIT TO REBUILD KNOWING
ACTUALLY RIGHT THANK YOU.
VERY VERY GOOD FOR MR BY SIR.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION -- THAT
WHICH IS AGAIN IS TO PASS AS A
MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS RICHARD
OVER THE DEAN OF THE SENATE FOR
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
I CAN TREAT YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER NIELSEN
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
AMAZING WORK -- AND WE LOOK FOR
TO WORK WITH YOU THE MONTHS COME
MISSING CHESTER IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
MORE LIKE I DEL.
I HERTZBERG HI [inaudible]
RIGHT NIELSEN.
I SAID I WIENER.
THAT IS CURRENTLY SIX ZERO VOTE --
CENTER WIENER IS CURRENTLY
PRESENTING IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP --
FULL OR TO ADD ON FOR
INDIVIDUALS -- IF YOU CAN GIVE
US ABOUT TWO MINUTES WE'RE GONNA
GET OUR PAPERWORK ORGANIZED AND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU TO
BE ABLE TO ADD ON IF WE CAN HAVE
I THINK WE'RE ONLY MISSING AT
THIS MOMENT [inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
IF WE CAN CHECK IN ONLINE
SENATOR WINNERS ETA THAT WOULD
BE GREAT.
DO I SAY THANKS TO OUR SERGEANTS
FOR ALL THE WORK TODAY
.
THE CENTER WILL RUN NIELSEN IS
GONNA AT START CRUISING HERE --
WE'RE GONNA START WITH A CONSENT
ITEM.
BETTER SECTOR I BELIEVE WERE MAY
SEEN VOTES FROM VICE CHAIR
MORLOCK.
CENTER NIELSEN IN CENTER WIENER
IN THIS.
ONE AND SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
WELL RUN THE CONSENT COUNTER.
CONTAIN CALENDAR CONSISTS OF
ITEM SIX SEVEN EIGHT IN THREE
SIX SEVEN EIGHT AND THREE
MISSING CHESTER PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MORLOCK.
WELL OKAY.
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER WE HAVE. SIX
SIX YEAR WHEN KEEP THE ROLL OPEN
MOMENTARILY AND WE'RE GONNA ADD
CENTER WIENER ON IN JUST A
MOMENT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE.
MOVING ON TO TEM SB TWO FOUR
NINE PLEASE GIVE US A MOMENT
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
NEVER MIND.
RIGHT.
NOW YOU'RE GOOD.
WE MUST INSIST ON ONE FORTY ONE
SO -- WHO'S MISSING HERTZBERG.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT THE GENERAL
WERE ONLY MADE A SCENE SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
TWO EIGHTY ONE MISSING CHESTER
HERTZBERG. FIVE THAT IS A FOUR
TO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT AND
WE'RE CLOSING DOWN.
THE ROLE WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM.
FOR IT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE
ZERO VOTE.
MISSING SOROKA PLEASE MORE A LOT.
MORE A LOT I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE NIELSEN NIELSEN
AYE WIENER. SIX ZERO WERE
MISSING CENTER WIENER WE'RE
TRACKING HIM DOWN THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE CURRENTLY
ENJOYS. EIGHTY THREE ZERO VOTE
AND THIS IS A DO PASSED TO
VETERANS AFFAIRS MISSING CHESTER
WARLOCK.
WARLOCK AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE NIELSEN.
THERE'S A NINE WIENER SIX SIX
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA GIVE THE
ROLE OPEN AND I WILL BE BACK TO
THAT.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO SB
FOR THIRTEEN CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
TWO ZERO VOTE THIS IS A DO
PASSED TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
IS ST CHESTER WICKWIRE I READ A
LOT OR A LOT I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
FIX YOUR VOTE KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN FOR CENTER WINNER WILL BE
COMING BACK TO THAT.
WE ARE MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TEN AS BEFORE FOURTEEN THIS IS A
DO PASS -- TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE
ZERO VOTE MISS LANCASTER
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT NIELSEN.
YES THE NINE SEVEN EIGHT ZERO
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE ON ITEM NUMBER
TEN NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB. SIX SIX THREE TWO
PASSES AMENDED TO VETERANS
AFFAIRS CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR
ZERO MISS LANCHESTER MORE A LOT.
MORE LOCK I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE NIELSEN.
THE NINE SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL
EASE OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLL
DOWN THANK YOU SO MUCH AND FIND
THE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB ONE
FORTY SEVEN THIS IS A DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
MISS LANCASTER.
MORE LIKE EARLY SEVENTIES HI
DAIMLER RIGO BIPARTISAN THAT IS
AT SEVEN ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING DOWN THE ROLE.
WE'RE GONNA I SEE IT WE'RE GONNA
RECESS MOMENTARILY WE ARE --
EIGHTY IS ON THE HUNT -- FOR
SENATOR WIENER.
WHO'S IN COMMITTEE AND WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU HERE IN JUST
A MOMENT THE CLOSE OF ALL
.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH I I
THINK WE ARE COMMENTING.
A SINNER LARA -- WAS -- PROMPTLY --
LATE -- EACH TIME I THINK WOMEN
YOU SEVERAL ARE SO -- HE PUT UP
WITH THE MANY OTHER COMMITTEES
THAT ARIEL I DALY A GOOD -- GOOD
TIMES GOOD TIMES NOON.
WRONG.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT IS THERE WERE NO -- GONNA BE
TURNED IT OVER ON CAN SENT --
WERE ON CONTENT WE HAVE ITEM SIX
SEVEN AND EIGHT AND WE ADDED --
ITEM THREE IS WELL CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE MISSING
CHESTER WIENER.
HI -- I SEVEN ZERO THAT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO AND WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWO FOUR NINE
TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A BIPARTISAN SIX ZERO VOTE
MISSING CHESTER WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE -- SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO THAT WERE CLOSE IN THE ROLE
IN THAT BILL IS ALPHA THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR NOW MOVING FORWARD
WITH SB TWO EIGHT ONE I THINK
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY DOWN WITH
THAT WE DISPENSED WITH.
IS THE TWO EIGHT ONE WE'RE NOW
MOVING FORWARD ON SB TWO NINE
FOUR THIS IS THE CHIEF PASTOR
PREPARATIONS SIX ZERO VOTE.
MESSAGES I'D WIENER ALRIGHT
SEVEN ZERO WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE.
IN THAT BILL IS OUR NOW MOVING
ON TO SB FIVE THREE SIX FOUR DO
PASSED A VETERANS AFFAIRS
CURRENT ENJOYS A SIX YEAR MUSLIM
CHESTER WIENER AYE.
AYE. SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
WILL CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
I ITEM NUMBER NINE IS BEFORE
THIRTEEN TO PASS ON BERMAN
EQUALITY CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX
ZERO MISS LANCHESTER.
I'D WIENER AYE SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS APPLE
CLOSING THE ROLE WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH ITEM TEN FOR
FOURTEEN WHEN I'M OF THE NINE
TWO WE'VE DISPENSED WITH ITEM
ELEVEN SB.
SIX SIX THREE WE'VE ALSO
DISPENSED WITH THE ITEM TWELVE
AB ONE FOUR SEVEN ST CHESTER
WIENER WE LISTENING.
ALL RIGHT.
SO MANY THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
BEST JOB.
THERE'S A GERMAN NOW WE ARE
GOING TO BE HAVING SOME HEAVY
HEARINGS COMING UP -- NEXT WEEK
BUT IN IN THE WEEK AFTER IN
PARTICULAR.
BRING A SLEEPING BAG -- AS WE'RE
GOING TO BE HERE FOR QUITE SOME
TIME